exzellent
so
auf gehts
ach fällt grad was ein
ich hab gerade gelesen, dass amazon
oder weiß nicht ob das nur amazon ist
wieder diese
ganze fake
angebote
naja was heißt fake angebote, das ist ja keine wirkliche fake angebote
aber diese extrem
überhyped black friday week
wieder gestartet ist
bei amazon
das ist massive überhyped
da gibt es zum größten teil nur müll
schau mal an
wir gucken mal schnell
bevor wir weiter basteln
also was haben wir denn hier lightning deals, all deals
amazon devices
ist immer nicht schlecht
tatsächlich
amazon devices kann man sich immer
wo sind denn amazon
amazon devices kann man sich immer geben
die sind immer relativ billig
ist das eine
triller pfeife oder so
was ist das denn
ach das ist ein sessel
wtf
was
das sieht nicht bequem aus
was ist das
ist das wenn man irgendwie
benommen ist, dass man blut in den kopf kriegt oder
wtf
ok normalerweise geht das
das sieht nicht bequem aus oder
das ist bequem, ich glaube nicht dass es bequem ist
oin chat
da haben wir hier exe2311
gwoz13
kuschrenard, den namen werde ich nie aussprechen können
der renax ist da
clocks HD
flow690, kaisi698,
zepcon7
einfach 13
ok auch gut
m11 bro
eviort
ich glaube nicht dass es bequem ist, das sieht aus wie so
das sieht aus wie
also
das was razer für gamer ist
ist das für
ich möchte irgendwas
stylisches haben was wahrscheinlich nicht bequem ist
ich darf ja nichts sagen was stühle angeht
ich darf ja echt nichts sagen was stühle angeht
mein büro stuhl hat mehr gekostet
als das ding
aber gut
ich darf ja wirklich nichts sagen
extremely
neuen monate, dankeschön für den sub
weeps out
oder in, man weiß es nicht
schwank von tag zu tag
wo sind dann amazon
devices, amazon devices
sind wirklich immer günstig
ich glaube die anzeige ist kaputt
ich gucke immer was gibt es
was gibt es für amazon devices
das ist immer interessant
und als nächstes
gucke ich immer was es für smart home devices gibt
oder netzwerk
manchmal gibt es was günstiges aber der rest ist ziemlich sinnlos
was hast du für einen büro stuhl
den hier
mit dieser
der lene hier
mit der kopfstütze hier
das teil sieht nicht so aus
als wäre es teuer, ist aber teuer
aber ist legit der geilste
büro stuhl den es gibt
jetzt kommen die leute wieder an und sagen
herrmann miller, herrmann miller
sag euch das ding, beste
das heißt nicht dass es nicht auch noch
andere gute büro stühle gibt
aber bis jetzt
ist der der beste
übrigens wisst ihr
was ich witzig finde
ich habe gerade unten
ein bisschen radio angemacht
als ich abendessen war
und ich habe ja vor einer weile was getwittert
muss ich gerade nochmal sagen
was
der frazier hat ein video hochgeladen
das glaube ich jetzt nicht
dann muss der mit mir auch ein video aufnehmen
an weihnachten
lehnst du dich viel an die kopfstütze an
ehrlich gesagt
nicht so
mittlerweile mehr
weil ich noch so einen kopfkissen dran habe
der friseur hat ein video hochgeladen
ernsthaft
ich reagiere
auf erstes video
null 10 jahre her
ich muss
ich kann
der frazier
exellent
was macht der denn hier
auf einmal
ich habe jetzt glaube ich schon
20 mal angefangen weil ich überhaupt
nicht mehr weiß wie das überhaupt geht
mit den videos aufnehmen
was ist das überhaupt für eine
kackaufflösung alter
ja kengi du machst gleich weiter
aber ich denke mein cut am ende
und am anfang setzen wird wohl ganz easy sein
also eins muss man ja mittlerweile sagen
früher
haben wir die leute immer gesagt der fabian sieht aus
wie 17 oder 18 oder so
mittlerweile sieht er aus wie 23
aber er ist 36
der ist so alt wie ich
ja
kommt wahrscheinlich nur durch die detovierung
ansonsten würde er wahrscheinlich weiter aussehen
wie 18
ich mache ein video
und das ist jetzt glaube ich 5 jahre her
das letzte video auf meinem channel gekommen ist
so war das nicht gemeint
ist mir eigentlich egal
ich fand es immer witzig weil die leute es
geschrieben haben
oder was dachte ich mir eigentlich bin heute morgen aufgewacht
also kurzes storytelling
und ich kann mir also
ich will mir jetzt nicht im stream
30 minuten video angucken
das muss ich mir selbst mal
in ruhe angucken und dann irgendein blödes
kommentar drunter schreiben was macht
er denn überhaupt ich reagiere auf erstes video
das ist wo wir zusammen mit der sylvaner
gespielt haben oder
whatever war so das standard
ding
ja
Fabian
du ey ey
okay
ich bin der letzte der sagen darf ich hab schon immer
gesagt ja
der fabian
der hatte falls ihr das nicht kennt
der hat nen
nen fitness channel mal gemacht
so leute
der fabian hat mal nen fitness channel gemacht
weil der hat übelst krasse
muskelstells gemacht
und der hat teilweise
auch mit dem longboard und den
pflegeprodukten für heransatz der hat
übelst viele views teilweise bekommen
und dann hat er einfach aufgehört
der hätte weitermachen müssen
ich sag euch so wie es ist der fabian
der hätte der größte
menner beauty channel in deutschland
werden können
der kel der sieht wie
wie geschaffen dafür aus
sowas zu machen der hat ahnung davon
ich mein der hat das nicht umsonst gelernt
und arbeitet auch seit jahren quasi
in dieser branche
und es gibt viel zu wenige
männliche
beauty channels auf youtube
der fabian
könnte der größte deutsche beauty
channel sein keine frage
hätte das mal weiter gemacht aber ich weiß
ich weiß ich könnte sicherlich auch einer
äh der zumindest
ja eigentlich größte nicht
aber ganz gut
laufenden channel haben wenn ich was machen würde ja
nein das ist
Männer nicht egal
das ist überhaupt nicht so man denkt vielleicht
dass es eben vielleicht mag das
vielleicht mag das
anteilmäßig Männern egal
aber es gibt immer noch genug und es gibt
auf youtube kaum beauty
Männer beauty channels die man sich
geben kann glaube ich zumindest ich hab keine ahnung
ja ja wir labern
immer mal ab und zu im discord so
alle zwei jahre oder so
alle paar wochen mal oder alle paar monate mal
aber es ist ich sage
das war schon immer so dass wir
jetzt teilweise
mal irgendwie einen jahr lang
kaum kontakt hatten oder so und dann mal ein bisschen telefoniert
haben und so aber
ich sage es wie es ist wenn mich der fabian
jetzt anrufen würde und sagen hier
keine ahnung er braucht hilfe bei ihm ich würde ihm sofort
helfen ja
also es ist
nicht so dass wir uns nicht leiden können oder so
wir haben
nur gerade wenig was wir zusammen machen können wir sind ja
die ganze zeit auf der suche dass wir
ein spiel wieder finden was wir zusammen spielen kann
aber irgendwie gibt es da nichts ja
ähm it's waffel
im december gibt
es wieder ein paar videos wenn ich es endlich schaffe
so ich wollte jetzt mal kurz amazon
durchgucken bevor wir bevor wir weitermachen
ja kengi das ist hier big brain
ich bin da jetzt auf den geschmack mal wieder mit dem
kabugen gesprochen ja
ähm vor
f*** mich nicht
es war in monaten oder so
waren wir essen
in frankfurt hier wir waren hier essen heute
ich zeige es euch mal ähm sushi
frankfurt oh wie hieß das ding
äh der willi brandplatz schreibt man
übrigens anders
ähm hier kamon noodle sushi
kamon das habe ich euch sogar schon mal gesagt hier
kamon noodle sushi bar
äh was der kabu macht ich also
ich erzähle euch das jetzt nicht im detaill
weil ich weiß nicht ob ihr das will und also geht das
soll ich euch das selbst erzählen wenn überhaupt
äh der ist bei einem
ich umschreibe das mal so der ist bei einem
recht großen deutschen auto hersteller
und macht da
irgendwelche frag mich nicht
stonks
sachen
einfach wieder entdeckt excellent
exellent ja genau hier waren wir letztens
futtern und das ist wirklich poggers
das war aber noch wo es wärmer war und wo
noch nicht corona am start war und übrigens
ein bisschen was witzig ist ich habe ja vor einer
weile ich hab ja vor einer weile
getwittert und zwar
was ich witzig fand wo sie am 10
die coronamaßnahmen
äh
irgendwann hier
beschlossen haben
und was ich gehe
genau also
ich habe ja geschrieben ah ja lockdown november die haben
ja quasi groß angekündigt
corona slowdown lockdown
nur im november und dann setzen wir uns wieder zusammen
und ich hab damals schon gesagt
leute diese aussage mit 4 wochen
das ist doch einfach nur
um die leute zu beruhigen
und was kam vorher für eine
news im radio ich weiß radio
2020 und jetzt habe ich gesagt
ja also wir könnten
das auch bis 2012
machen
ja
ja und da habe ich mir gedacht max
du hast es mal wieder recht
aber man muss
immer ehrlich sagen wenn es nach mir geht
äh
2020 nicht 2012
keck w
ähm
was ist denn
also leute jetzt jetzt jetzt
jetzt hab ich
jetzt hab ich problem also warte also
warte mal also das hier ist
keck w
das hier ist
keck triple w und was ist das hier
ne
ne ne ne
ne moment
das ist w
das ist das schon
quad u quad u
und das ist 6 double u
das hört sich aber scheiße an
keck triple w ist viel besser
aber keck triple w
wäre das hier
keck w
triple w
keck w w
das klingt aber doof
ich bleib bei
keck triple w
so schauen wir mal kurz drüber
also was was haben wir hier bei amazon
zu bieten
amazon wir sind ja bei den coolen leuten
amazon das ist ja nicht hier amazon
zeug da das ist ja auch nicht
ubuntu sondern es ist
chat
äh
herz 93
achja guck da mal an
das ist aber nicht die die das ist vom gleichen
hersteller witzigerweise
das vom gleichen hersteller aber
ähm irgendwas
anderes wir können aber mal gucken
ob man flashen kann ihr wisst ja ich bin
immer für steckdosen leistend jemand
ich hab mittlerweile so viele steckdosen
die kann ich überhaupt nicht mehr loswerden
ähm so zeigt mal hier
gosund
smart power strip
tas motor
gucken wir mal ob das geht
gosund
schauen wir mal
tas motor
ey gosund
gosund p1 power strip
p2 power strip
strip
lgb led strip
power strip
sag mal wie was
so wie viele power strips haben die
haben die denn das ist ja oder
das ist das ist
das ist die freedom variante
hell yeah
wo hab ich mein wo hab ich mein
kokona
wo ist meine wo ist meine wo ist er
wo ist er
ich find den nicht
wo ist er chat
den da hab ich
den da hab ich den hab ich
ähm
wo ist er
ok systematisch
da ist er nicht
da ist er auch nicht
wo ist er denn da ist er
exellent
da ist er
der hat ja auch ein bisschen
dachschaden der wendler
so also
schauen wir mal kann man das flashen
gosund p1 das ist der ne
das ist der hier 100 pro
gosund steht da irgendwas von p1 dabei
ach guck mal läuft
prima mit tas mutter das ist natürlich das erste was die leute schreiben
lull
äh
darfst du das ist ne das ist ne gute
frage darfst du das egal noch spielen
ohne dass du in seiner telecam gruppe bist allerdings
woher willst du wissen dass ich nicht
in seiner telecam gruppe bin
das weißt du ja gar nicht
in der wendler telecam gruppe
so also das ist interessant das
funktioniert schonmal exellent
da muss man guck mal das ist der
gleiche scheiß kennen ihr das doch irgendwie
koko z0
kommt euch das doch irgendwo bekannt vor
haben wir das
schonmal irgendwo gesehen
kommt uns das nicht
irgendwie bekannt vor diese
aufschrift
mir kommt es fast so als
wäre es gestern gewesen
was meint er
äh kilfel du warst gestern nicht da
deswegen kannst du es
nicht wissen guck mal was ich gestern
gemacht hab
ähm
wo sind meine videos
da
ach du warst da hast du mich
gebanet guck mal da
das haben wir gestern aufgemacht da ist halt exakt
exakt der gleiche
der gleiche chip drin hier
da
koko koko z0
vl1 war das auch immer
s
Und noch zwei goso natürlich die ich absolut nicht brauche dann habe ich irgendwie noch keine zwölf cellis übrig und alle möglichen dinger
Ich kaufe mir das jetzt nicht das ist total rausgeschmissenes geld
Nein nein nein nein wir bestellen den nicht chat es sei denn ihr giftet mir jetzt vier subs dann bestelle ich den
Vier subs giften 20 euro und dann bestelle ich ihn aber ansonsten bestell ich nicht
Wobei ne warte mal warte mal vier bringen gar nichts acht acht weil ich krieg ja nur die hälfte
Ich krieg ja nur die hälfte
Und die gibt es genau nein nein es macht jetzt wirklich alle das
Bevor ich mein primes abzüglich nice nice
Depp 1899 dankeschön für den sub huge subscription ob es falsche sound
Nice dankeschön so ich wollte jetzt aber schon die ganze zeit mal
Amazon die weiße schnell durchgucken
Da ist aber nix spannendes dabei das lohnt also diese feier feier sachen lohnt sich immer wenn amazon was im angebot hat wenn man das braucht
Gibt's gibt's wieder hd 10
günstiger
Ja das geht
Kelfeld stufe 1 dankeschön für den sub excellent subscription
Nice
Für amazon slayda teddy sieben monate oh jetzt kommt jetzt kommt das gem train auch noch
Du hast dich getötet du hast dich getötet
Jetzt jetzt chat chat jetzt jetzt willst du das chat wissen
Slayda teddy sieben monat dankeschön huge sub wen haben wir jetzt noch game hq 3 monat auch
Ein richtig nicer sub
Jetzt kommt noch der kill filter exit 23111 gifted
Der chat will jetzt wirklich wissen dass ich den kack bestell ich glaube es nicht
Aber
Chat ich habe nicht gesagt dass das gilt wenn es alle einzeln machen
Ok drei monate drei monate hallo 2 dankeschön für den sub
Ok haben wir jetzt
Kussis niggas 3 dankeschön für den sub excellent ok leute ich glaube wir haben 8 subs ich muss den kram jetzt bestellen also wo haben wir das denn jetzt
Wo ist es hier gosund
Gosund excellent und oh wo ist mein handy für to factor authentifizierung nicht da
Macht aber nix ich kann einfach vom handy aus bestellen ich bestell einfach vom handy aus besser
excellent
Emma emerson hier emerson also wie heißt das ding
Gosund
Power strip
Ok da ist er black friday deal 20 prozent off
Alles klar add to basket jawoll
Warum genau soll man eigentlich den non deal preis
Anklicken bei amazon das ergibt doch überhaupt keinen sinn
Ok chat
Proceed to check out
Bam
Place order
Buy now bam
Tja chat ich
Das seid ihr jetzt selbst dran schuld ihr habt jetzt quasi
Geld zum fenster rausgeschmissen ja
Ihr habt subs gegiftet und ich habe mir was gekauft was ich überhaupt nicht brauche
Und ich habe mir was gekauft was ich überhaupt nicht brauche excellent so muss das sein
Aber trotzdem dankeschön an die ganzen subs
Kannst du dir dann im stream verschenken nachdem du das geflasht hast
Ja könnte ich machen allerdings weiß ich nicht wie das rechtlich ist mal angenommen ich flasche das und es fackelt einem das haus ab
Das wird wahrscheinlich nicht wegen dem geflashten abfackeln aber vielleicht sagt er das dann bin ich da noch dran schulden ne ne das mache ich nicht
Ich muss ja muss ich an alles denken okay ich muss nur mal schnell noch die smart smart home deals gucken
Konnte man das nicht filtern
Hatten die nicht einen filter für smart home
Smart home also alles wahrscheinlich müll aber gucken wir mal kurz die go so
Was wieviel lumen haben die lumen die haben gar keine lumen die haben was was haben die
Also meistens haben die 800 oder
Wo steht da was was haben die soviel text mich interessiert wie hell die sind hier 800
Aber wahrscheinlich sagten die die meisten rgb lichter sagten richtig deswegen kaufe ich mir ja auch die teuren von liveaxe weil die sind ziemlich gut
Die sind unnötig teuer
Was ist das denn classic die sind
Moment ist das ist das eine led
Lampe die versucht auf klübirne zu machen sehe ich das richtig
Ist das ist das für die rentner die quasi sagen mit klübirne war früher alles besser und dann sagst du opa guck mal ich hab eine klübirne für dich
Und dann ist es led
Exzellent so muss das sein
Ja aber wozu kann die kann die überhaupt irgendwas kann man die dimmen oder so kann gehen
500 lumens das ist ja nix
Filaments hier
Ja aber 500 lumens da brauchst du ja da musst du ja schon mal vier stück in der flur hängen dass es da überhaupt ordentlich warm wird
Wie viele subscriptions für die lampe die gibt es noch nicht
Was ist denn der vorteil jetzt mal jetzt mal ernsthaft chat was ist der vorteil
Gegenüber eine led lampe die quasi ein fake
Klübirn licht macht versus eine rgb lampe die ich von der freundinke lichter
Bevor ich die lichter beobachte habe ich mir eine lgb lichter
Bevor ich die lichter beobachte habe ich mir eine lgb lichter beobachte
Ich kann ja mein rgb ja auch komplett einstellen sowohl wie weiß weiß also die temperatur von weiß
Und die farbe und alles da kriege ich mit sicherheit ziemlich ähnliche farbe hin
Moment was was ist ihr bau ist das die farbe und alles da kriege ich mit sicherheit eine ziemlich ähnliche farbe hin
Die farbe und alles da kriege ich mit sicherheit eine ziemlich ähnliche farbe hin äh moment was was ist sie bau ist
wird ok
Das kommt drauf an
Was du damit machst
Standardmäßig nicht na also das sind übrigens zwei komplett unterschiedliche paar schuhe sebaro wird iow ist
Paravirtualisierter treiber für vms also zum beispiel für iow und netzwerk und sowas
Coemo ist quasi der teil von kvm der die
Ganze ganzen tools zur verfügung stellt die man verwendet vom wirtmanager bis zu irgendwelchen
Display ausgaben treibern sonst was
Das sind zwei komplett unterschiedliche paar schuhe und ja wenn du wenn du
Kvm in kvm betreibst dann ist es nested virtualisierung aber das eine hat mit dem anderen erstmal nichts zu tun
Wenn ich es für eine windows installation als treiber brauche also die
Die normalen hetzer server die sind wahrscheinlich
Also die server auktionen die sind ja hardware und die hetzer cloud server habe ich ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung gebt mal wird watt ein
In dein in deiner vm hier gebt das hier mal ein
Wird watt dann siehst du was da drunter läuft
Und ist das ist das ein esx oder kvm dann ist es nested virtualisierung ja und die chancen sind da sogar relativ groß dass es nicht funktioniert
Weil damit nested virtualisierung funktioniert
Müsstest du auf server seite also sprich sprich hetzer müsst ihr das einschalten und ich könnte mir vorstellen das hat hetzer gar nicht
So mal schnell die smart home dinger durch scrollen was wir hier haben
Oh nee gefällt moment habe ich jetzt schon das richtige smart home
Ja smart home also schauen wir mal was haben die denn hier
Eatswitz brauchen wir nicht
save on smartwares
ein feuerlöscher
Und das ist das
Save on smartwares ein feuerlöscher
Feuerlöscher ist neuerdings smartware
Wird watt sagt kvm ja dann ist es auf jeden fall nested virtualisierung wenn du da noch mal kvm drin startest
Und es ist fraglich ob es überhaupt geht
Smartwares extinkt was genau ist smart an dem feuerlöscher
Aber
Warum ist das smart
Brauchen wlan leuchtmittel eigentlich viel mehr strom als zigbee leuchtmittel
Nein
Nachdem die beide in der eben im strom stecken macht es keinen unterschied der unterschied zwischen wlan und zigbee geräten ist
Wenn überhaupt entscheidend wenn sie an der batterie hängen
Aber der stromverbrauch zwischen der wlan birne und einer zigbee birne ist
vernachlässigbar gering
Smart smart der feuerlöscher sehr schön das ist ein wi-fi feuerlöscher
Ich meine es reicht ja schon dass er feuer löschen kann das ist schon ziemlich
Gigaset jetzt sowas gibt es noch
Es waren so die
Das waren die sachen die man früher sich immer das sieht aber auch das sieht aber echt aus wie
Wie 1995 guckt euch das mal an also wenn das nicht boomer hardware ist dann weiß ich auch nicht
Ich könnte wetten die dinger gibt seit 20 jahren schon sehen schon immer gleich aus so
Ok das scheint wirklich angesagt zu sein diese dinger hier
Inna also der name ist ja mal absolut beschissen ich hab also
Warum
Erstens erinnert mich das an den telekom messenger kann sich noch eine an den tl an in die telekom whatsapp konkurrenz erinnern immer
So hieß das ding immer so und dieses ding wurde eingestellt schon vor ewig kann also dass
Das es war es war von anfang an klar dass das ding sacken wird
Aber ja kurz also so und das ist nicht immer das ist inna und ich dachte eigentlich dass es out dass es spätestens seit
Flicker flicker nicht mehr angesagt ist dachte ich es ist hinten dran überhaupt nicht mehr angesagt
inner
Ausbrechen außer dass es ein trendiges logo und trendige name hat
Ja aber wie der chat gesagt hat filament ist angesagt
Okay, was haben wir hier sonst noch zu bieten also gehen wir das ganze immer schnell durch net few outbraun
crap
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie meine kamera nur von einem anderen china hersteller
haben die ert sp ert sp ohne ert sp wird das nicht gekauft ert sp ert sp
not usable
manufacturer does not provide any information
tja useless shit useless china shit
3d drucker filament nein eher nicht
ich
Moment war ich jetzt stehen gestehen geblieben
Jbl tecken die dinger sind auch ganz gut aber ich kauf mir jetzt nicht noch eine wlan steckdose. Ich sag so
Die sind die sind auch ganz okay
Dann gibt es hier irgendwelche
Strips
500 12 voll strips
Seht ihr das irgendwo
Und es ist so was von egal 12 volls 12 volls okay
Haben wir hier sonst noch sennheiser dings kopfhörer
hat keinen bedarf
Tekken outdoor socket das kauf ich mir
Moment der ist aber nicht
Das okay die haben den photoshop bild mit wasser drauf gemacht das ding hält nix aus
Was hat das für ein ip rating ip
IP
IP 44 ist ja nix IP 44 ist nicht waterproof IP 44 ist mal gar nix
IP wikipedia
IP Schutzklassen wikipedia
IP Schutzart hier also genau das ist ja so eingeteilt
Genau das ist staub geschützt also guck mal
Das ding ist staub geschützt und schutz gegen allseitige spritzwasser also
Mit aro und krach ein bisschen bisschen
Vielleicht ein bisschen regen also das ist nicht sonderlich wasserdicht das ding
Also ich habe ein paar IP
Technik so dosen doch staub geschützt ist es halt
Auch jetzt nicht sonderlich sonderlich sonderlich viel ja also ab ip 44 ist nicht so der wahnsinn ich habe ein paar dos ich glaube ip
Ne 56 65 ich kann es aber nicht merken wie rum die sind wirklich richtig richtig
Gut die haben auch noch mal so ein gummi isoliert also gummi drin wenn du zumachst und so
Ja
Okay also sonderlich allerdings ich ich bin trotzdem am überlegen das zu kaufen weil
Ich bräuchte für die pumpe im fischteich sowas
Aktuell muss man dahinter laufen und das an und ausschalten
Halten das nächste problem ist ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ob das wlan bis dahin reicht
ich
Ich werde es mir mal ich werde es mir mal bookmarken ich bookmarke mir das mal und dann gucke ich mir das mal später an
Okay
So
Dann schauen wir noch mal schnell durch noch mal die erst seit ich ja safe und was maxiko
Oh
Schalter gäbe ich nicht so viel geld aus so übelster crap
Auch mehr crap
Ja so so so ein staubsauger und ein hackfleisch drehdingen das passt ja schon mal gut zusammen so gut zusammen
Der bosch was was für ein ding so so pro animal
Meine katz das so pro animal sieht habe ich da meine zweifel mein katz hat es nicht so mit dem staubsauger guckt mal hier
Ah
Was meint ihr was meint ihr wer gewonnen hat
Wer hat gewonnen
Die katz
Nä
Der staubsauger hat gewonnen weil die katze hat es überhaupt nicht gecheckt die hat den staubsauger sich angeguckt hat ihn erst mal so anvisiert
Und dann hat sie sich gedacht ach die ist da ist ja gar nicht gefährlich und hat sich hier hingelegt und dann ist ja der
staubsauger von hinten auf den arsch
Gefahren und sie hat zwei meter sprung nach vorne gemacht und ist abgehauen
So also alles müll
Nix gescheites bei
Restrictions apply
Was?
Okay da sind wir schon wieder mal durch es gab nix
Okay, da sind wir schon wieder mal durch es gab nix
Es gibt nix nix gescheites lightning deals noch mal schnell schauen
Ah yes unterhose, unterhose kannst du tatsächlich mal wieder ein paar
Aber die nicht mectem die sind ganz schön teuer wieviel sind denn das
Mectem
Alles klar mectem
Ist das wenn man seine füße irgendwie
Kaputt machen will oder
Irgendwie anderen kraft das braucht doch alles keiner weil ergonomisch sind die dinger nett
Wenn man das braucht dann sollte man sich die selbst anfertigen lassen was sagst du zu apples abend cpus
ehrlich gesagt relativ wenig weil ich mich damit nicht großartig beschäftigt beschäftigt habe
Also ich weiß nicht bei mir geht gerade bei audio equipment
Sound und funktion eindeutig über die optik und ich muss euch ehrlich sagen ich finde die meisten
Guten audiogeräte auch so ganz hübsch auch wenn sie halt nicht super fancy aussehen
Also das hier einbrecherhandschuhe
Erstmal zum fensterscheiben einschlagen oder was macht man damit für die coronademos Keine ahnung wofür man das braucht
Wenn man nachts durch die hauptwache muss
Ja dafür ist da würde ich noch andere sache mitnehmen
Allerdings nachts in der hauptwache
Könnte wahrscheinlich mittlerweile ganz ok wieder sein weil die machen ja wenn es kalt wird immer immer nachts die hauptwache auf für obdachlose
Und da ist halt auch polizei und alles am start
Ne ne ne ne nix dabei
dasSDkarten sammle sammle ding aber
ne ne ne ne
nix dabei
ist ein sd karten sammel sammel ding oder sd karten sammel stellts ehrlich gesagt braucht
es kein mensch ich habe hier ein kästchen und da kommt das rein so leute also was das lego von 2011
was
das nimmt echt langsam ausmaße an
forschen ist es gelungen die sense ach das kenne ich das kenne ich das haben wir doch
sogar auf youtube schon gesehen mit dem mit dem mikrofon abhören
oder ist es was anderes also einem forschen ist es gelungen die sensoren eines smarten staubsauger
von show me in ein laser mikrofon um zu wandeln mit dem audio aufwärts und die aha und welchem
mit welchem modell und der nationaluniversitets singapfel oh s5 das ist ein den habe ich das
ist den den ich das ist mein den staubsauger habe ich s5 s50 ist es klar ist das gleiche aber
das macht nix ich habe ja mal mit customfirma geflasht da kann keiner von außen drauf zugreifen
das ist mal big brain das ist mal big brain guck mal hier mit solchen vorrichtungen lassen
sich beispielsweise gespräche über eine größere entfernung mittels der schwingungen der fenster
aufnehmen richtig big brain aber wisst ihr was unabhängig davon was man daran sieht wie
genau diese messgeräte mittlerweile sind
ach so die musste die firme des staubs so das konnte man wissen was ich viel geiler finden
würde wenn es customfirma gebe die das eingebaut hat wenn es customfirma gibt die das mitbringt
dass ich das auch ausprobieren könnte ach so mit der technik konnte das forscherteam
per lautsprecher abgespielte zahlen vollen über die schwingungen eines papierkorbs aufnehmen
gut wenn die das über lautsprecher abgespielt haben weiß man nicht wie laut das ganze war
auch konnten melodien oder das das geschlecht woher wollen die wissen ob das eine frau ist
oder ein mann ist der da spricht 2020 darf der nicht mein gender assume der staubsauger
einfach das geht nicht dann ist die anzeige direkt raus das ist triggert genau mir ist
etwas aufgefallen war wieder was ich mir gedacht habe wenn ich das wenn ich das jetzt auf
twitter posten würde da werden wir alle wahrscheinlich ultra ultra triggert und zwar ich war mal
ich war mal die vm kurz nebenbei an die promise gleich aber progress action also also einer
meiner nachbarn ist eine türkische familie und die bauen gerade ihr haus um und die haben
dafür türkische und zum größten teil türkische handwerker am start denkt sich ja eigentlich
keiner was bei heute war ich beim italiener hat mir einen schnitzel geholt und was war
da der wurde renoviert und die hatten was hatten die da italienische handwerker so
oder habe ich mir so überlegt okay würde ich jetzt auf twitter gehen und schreiben
ich will mein haus umbauen aber bitte nur deutsche handwerker dann würden sich alle
wieder aufregen wohnort liegt beim italiener schnitzel ja weil die haben schnitzel schnitzeltag
einmal die woche warum soll ich beim italiener kein schnitzel kaufen warum sollten die da
schlechter können als andere hat gerade einer gesappt habe ich das nur gehört oder nicht
gesehen hast du die schon mal mit rein ist die musik zu laut kann das sein die macht
übel krach was ist denn hier los aber kurz bisschen leiser oder ich überspringen das
einfach mal das macht so viel krach ja schon besser hast du dich schon mal mit 3d ah hier
x ein wahnsinnig tolles logo was ich gepastet habe hast du dich schon mal mit 3d druckern
auseinander gesetzt ja als ich mir einen gekauft habe ich habe den hier i3 s mega n
cubic i3 mega s den habe ich 1337 so ein ding hat kein mikro die haben die das die
haben das mit dem laser sensor gemessen den man der also guckt mal das hier ist der staubsauger
das ist nämlich der gleich staubsauger ich hab so und der hat so einen laser mit dem
man die räume erfasst so und mit diesem laser haben die vibrationen im fenster mitgeschnitten
und diese vibrationen am fenster haben sie zurück umgewandelt in gesprache 100 bits
habe ich gar nicht gesehen dankeschön für ungefähr ungefähr ein euro nice
ich scroll mal kurz durch ob ich irgendwelche sachen was hältst du von shit audio die sind
ganz gut ich weiß aber nicht wie man die ausspricht ob shit oder shit oder scheit keine ahnung
captain sieker hat gefragt gibt es für den esp 2 und ich zeige euch mal die frage mal
ansonsten da durften wir zuvor vorlesen gibt es für den esp 32 eine firmware die direkt
eine api mitbringt für die steuerung von rgb ja ja ja wie wärs damit ach moment der
ist ja nur für den esp 200 geht geht geht das motor auch für den esp 32 anscheinend
habe ich noch nie ausprobiert kannst du mal ausprobieren ansonsten wünschen esp 2866
da geht das motor auf jeden fall und das motor hat eingebaut so und dann gibt es noch dann
gibt es noch wie heißt das wled glaube ich das ist auch schon fix und fertig also captain
sieker da gibt es ein paar dinger musst du gucken was zu deiner hardware passt und was
zu deinem guck da ist nämlich direkt ein webinterface und so alles schon fertig musst du gucken was
zu deiner hardware passt und zu deinen lightstrips really good shit alles klar ok habe ich noch
was übersehen wupplos was ist denn das eigentlich für ein komisches wieso benutzt du dein chat
bot gar nicht mehr das ist eine gute frage frag mich nicht keine ahnung bin gerade gekommen
hast du bereits eine heizungsauslese software gezeigt nein habe ich noch nicht gemacht aber
mache ich später wie viel hast du für deinen freund mal workstation pro bezahlt ich glaube
49 euro mal dass es zu weihnachten günstiger gab aber du kannst aber irgendwelchen key shops
gucken da kriegst du vor allem der workstation 16 ist glaube ich das aktuelle für 490 oder so
ich wusste gar nicht dass du noch aktiv bist was heißt noch auf twitch bin ich seit drei
jahren ununterbrochen am start auf youtube was denn hier los warum ist mein teamax kaputt
mein teamax kaputt guck mal was ist hier los die haben bestimmt wieder irgendwelche settings
deprecated sodass hier unten wieder alles fort ist das sehen wir ein paar witzbolde
ja gut ich meine funktioniert noch aber was soll das hier mega beschissen aus ok repos
monaq s nee wo habe ich wo habe ich sein liegen rider rider projects monaq monaq s genau
so pull bam naja gut wir machen jetzt ich habe irgendwas lokales gemacht was wahrscheinlich
ziemlich unsinnig ist git reset minus minus hart origin master bam so alles gut ich habe
mich vorher gerade noch was gepusht dass wir heute weitermachen können bei der ganzen
geschichte heute erst gesehen hast du streams was ist das für ein komischer usernamen oder
ja wie gesagt ich bin schon ewig ewig am stream so wenn du mal guckst wenn du die letzten videos
mal anguckst war dann mal das ist ja so ungefähr zwei monate ist glaube ich die die historie auf
twitch ich war schon relativ oft und in letzter zeit aber ich mache halt anderes zeug als auf
youtube so und dann was man auch nicht oft genug zeigen kann es gibt sogar ein archiv wo man sich
alte sachen angucken kann wo das hier baro sich immer viel mühe gibt dass das alles zu machen
und dann sieht man das ist seit 2007 2017 guck mal was ist das september 2017 was habe ich da
gestreamt overwatch o m warum habe ich auf erwacht gestreamt was ist das battlefield
das ist world war world war 2 war das und da habe ich auf erwacht gestreamt
monka es das war nicht der erste stream ach nee das hier war auch nicht der erste stream sebaro
ich glaube du warst vielleicht nicht seit anfang an am start das kann sein oder ich glaube
ein paar streams sind lost in dings ich weiß gar nicht ehrlich gesagt genau erschief ich weiß
gar nicht mehr genau was mein erster live stream war mein erster live stream war wahrscheinlich
irgendeine bdo geschichte mit dem friseur oder so vermute ich mal ich hätte ein video für den aufwachstream
oder es muss so neue posten so funktioniert hacking wirklich aha die mädels erklär uns
das so so o fach in eine fahr informatik ihren erklär uns das exzellent ja das können wir uns
tatsächlich mal morgen angucken genau ich habe ich weiß ich habe auch mal battlefield 3 gestreamt
als einer der ersten streams ja da weiß ich noch vorigen so ein typ in chat gekommen ist
hat gemeint du streamstack man i don't know why so many viewers oder irgendwie so das war
metro das weiß ich noch das war eine runde auf metro und ich bin übelst abgegangen in der runde
wo ich wieder gedacht habe was zum toll was was will der typ jetzt eigentlich von mir aber
mittlerweile mache ich mir über dummes zeug ja gar keine gedanken mehr damals habe ich mir gedacht
ok da muss ja noch was dran sein aber mittlerweile weiß ich wenn der chat auf twitch was schreibt
ist das vollkommen irrelevant außer außer natürlich ist außer es ist ja dann ist es
was anderes aufwachen stream da ist immer sonntags da ist immer sonntags morgens keine ahnung so
zwischen zwischen also entweder geht es 9 30 los oder 10 30 und dann meistens so bis 14 30 oder
so vielleicht habe ich den in game gekillt ja das kann wirklich sein dass ich den in dass ich den
in game gebashed habe und er deswegen auf sauer war ein fünf tagen ok wir können heute noch
weitermachen kontinue ich würde eh nie meine trial resetten sowas sowas gehört sich nicht
br excellent soll ich so machen soll ich so machen oder so machen also ich glaube ein
bisschen kleiner ist nicht schlecht man kann das doch bestimmt gut lesen oder das kann man gut
lesen weil das macht auch nicht fett aber dafür finde ich sie die schriftart das ist richtig
nice ja das ist scharf genau also machen wir das bisschen kleiner so also es hat sich im
vergleich zum letzten mal rein optisch nicht allzu viel getan ich zeige euch noch mal was
zuletzt hier am start war was ist das denn ist mein farbschema kaputt ist mein farbschema
kaputt was ist hier los ist mein farbschema kaputt so sollte es eigentlich aussehen und so
sieht es jetzt aus warum das denn profile moment was ist warum ist das im arsch das
war irgendein update was das kaputt gemacht hat wo hab ich denn hier mein mein mein hier
warum füttern das denn aus warum habe ich permission denied auf meine eigenen repos
ach so moment ich habe es auch falsch gemacht meh mein terminal hat keinen bock auf meinen
color scheme das ist einfach weg mein color mein color so einfach fort habe ich gedacht
nee brauche man nicht mehr ja aber das ist ja mal richtig hängen geblieben hatte man
ich weiß woran das liegt der profil button ist weg wo sind der profile button alter knall
die knall und die leute gehen wir so auf den sack wo ist in der profil umschalten umschalten
button hin haben die den profil umschalten button weggemacht normalerweise konnte man
immer profile switchen das ist weg und ich habe jetzt nur noch ein unnamed profile das
ist falsch das ist verkehrt das ist das ist kaputt jetzt super bestimmt removed ja das
würde mich nicht wundern ok base 16 knob terminal installieren wir es halt wieder installieren
wir es halt wieder oder ist es deprecated ich weiß es gar nicht mehr please use um funktioniert
natürlich direkt ausführen was meinst du meinst du ich guck mir das vorher an was wollen
die jetzt von mir überhaupt base 16 base 16 night 80s 80s 80s will ich haben ok sieht
ok aus so habe ich jetzt in ok jetzt ist es da ok dann schauen wir mal besser allerdings
will ich nicht base 16 80s was habe ich denn hier was habe ich noch mal hier in meinem
profil drinnen gehabt base 16 tomorrow night hatte ich net 80s base 16 tomorrow repos
knob terminal ja das war das falsche base 16 tomorrow night what the fuck das ist ja jetzt
genau das gleiche oder ach so jetzt hat es ein zweites hinzugefügt jetzt hat er ein zweites
hinzugefügt ok wie aktiviert man das jetzt das default ok ah yes ok so aus welchen gründen
auch immer die meinen profil überschrieben haben ich weiß es nicht aber mein profil
ist back jetzt können wir loslegen die haben ein profil gelöscht deswegen ist es rechts
klingt warum löschen die einfach irgendwelche das ist doch voll für den arsch das wichtigste
color color was wird heute was wird heute gebastelt kamera bilderkennung also die bilderkennung
ich zeige bilderkennung funktioniert ja schon halbwegs x fatal dankeschön für den sub
17 monat das ist ja schon richtig ich kümmere mich erst mal drum dass der aufnehmen kann
wenn man motion detection hatte also so jetzt können wir hier repos monarch s ne wo hatte
ich rider monarch s da sind wir so ich habe gepullt pull alles klar passt watch run so
jetzt zeige ich euch erst mal wie es aktuell aussieht dazu muss ich aber erst mal ffm pack
anschmeißen cd download slash simple server stream also ich ich ich fake jetzt ein kameras
stream weil ich keinen bock habe immer wieder auf meine webcams zu connecten hier im hause
aus dem will ich nichts liegen ich muss noch mal kurz gucken was die testaufnahme von meiner
webcam war war das plupp zwei plupp zwei war der fitness typ den wir von youtube runtergeladen
haben zum testen flur zwei ist das glaube ich weiß ich genau flur zwei stream nur zwei
was übrigens mit flur überhaupt nichts zu tun hat ich weiß ich warum ich flur genannt
habe so flur ist was anderes ja tatsächlich da war mein chrome auf und da gucken wir uns
an 1 2 2 zack so und gut achso ja motion detection funktioniert erst wenn ich den motion detection
server einschalte ich mache noch mal hier aus ich weiß ich ob der von anfang an laufen
muss ehrlich gesagt so und wenn jetzt motion wenn jetzt wenn jetzt einer ins bild kommt
dann gibt es ein rotes dreieck dreieck vier eck drum herum und es steht dran was er erkannt
hat aktuell ist der hardcoded match da nur auf personen die erkannt wurden und das ist
auch trainiert auf personen werden erkannt also sprich der erkennt manchmal sonst andere
sachen als baseball schläger und sowas warum funktioniert die motion erkennung nicht habe
ich was vergessen warum funktioniert die motion erkennung nicht ok ich habe irgendwas kaputt
gemacht ich habe irgendwas kaputt gemacht objekte detection wartet mal ich muss mal
kurz font eins kleiner machen 18 wollen wir haben 18 hat sich das jetzt geändert
das ändert sich nur was neu auf macht oder wie aber auch ein bisschen doof
ja ja steuerung plus mausrad macht aber nicht guck mal wenn ich hier steuerung plus
raus mausrad machen mache ich eine neue datei auf dann hat er sich das aber nicht gemerkt
oder oder doch ok er hat sich gemerkt scheiß drauf also warum geht die objekte erkennung
nicht objekte detection service da ist er objekte detection service der müsste eigentlich
funktionieren warum geht warum geht die objekte erkennung nicht weil ich ein kacknub bin
weil ich das wichtigste vergessen habe guck mal die objekte detection die funktioniert
detektet die funktioniert ich habe bloß noch nicht eingestellt dass er das an einen kleinen
zurück schickt das ist natürlich fail so pass mal auf die objekte detection geht jetzt
steht er nämlich gleich detektet da kurz warten dass er durchs bild läuft detektet
ich schicke so nicht an klein zurück oh bin ich doof ja ich habe das ich habe das hier
umge- ich habe das hier ein bisschen ein bisschen umgebaut die ganze geschichte und zwar ich
habe das ich habe das so gemacht dass das alles ein bisschen essen miteinander kommuniziert
also sprich wenn der motion detektor motion detektet hat dann published er nur ein event
dass er motion erkannt hat und dann braucht man irgendeiner auf das event lauscht und
der dann was an den kleinen schickt habe ich hier nicht eingestellt vorwärts vorwärts
to clients also muss ich jetzt nicht auf detection sondern auf detection result oder irgendwie
sowas lauschen bin mir nicht ganz sicher mehr was ich da gebaut habe wenn ich ehrlich bin
detection result muss ich glaube ich drauf lauschen wer weiß was ich da gestrickt habe
und die feind was habe ich denn da gemacht moment wir konsole die bang mal kurz welches
freund das ist asp.net core weil die ob die motion detection muss schon funktionieren
dass wir jetzt bei motion detection aufnehmen können konsole die bang beste so siehts aus
detection result message muss ich drauf listen und die feind das funktioniert schon aber
da ist irgendwas undy feind war ich denn da undy feind ich sehe ich sehe was ich verkehrt
gemacht habe ich habe das kleinseitig doch überhaupt nicht angepasst guck mal so passt
mal auf so und jetzt jetzt funktioniert es nämlich unit test wer will den unit test schreiben
tests in 2020 so jetzt schauen wir mal was ich da für eine message zurück kriege undy
feind hier da also ich krieg zurück cam summary ok das könnte ich auch das könnte ich da
auch einzeln rausholen ehrlich gesagt aber egal forward to clients muss fort das mache
man mal das brauche ich jetzt also die streamurl steht drin das will ich vielleicht auch nicht
an client weiter schicken werden wir mal gucken summary summary brauche ich also cam und summary
also haben wir hier let cam gleich ja das hier ist message wo ich es nennen soll message
dann funktioniert das auch wieder mit motion detection message cam und summary gleich so
und jetzt sollte das wieder funktionieren ha ha person bam funktioniert ok alles klar
motion detection funktioniert ich habe plus den dass das signalisieren nicht angepasst
das open cv nein das nicht open cv das ist tensor flow lite was da unten drunter ist
aber ich will mich da nicht mit fremden fremden federn schmücken das ist mehr oder weniger
fertig und ich benutze das einfach nur also sind weder meine trainings daten noch habe
ich das irgendwie programmiert oder so ich benutze das einfach nur ah ja jetzt funktioniert
ok ja excellent excellent ok wisst ihr was wir noch machen können ich habe ich habe
eine richtig gute idee ich habe eine richtig gute idee wir können gucken ob das ist nämlich
relativ easy zu berechnen wir können gucken wir nennen das primary image color oder so
wir können gucken ob das bild dunkel ist wenn das bild dunkel ist dann machen wir den
rahmen weiß und wenn das bild hell ist machen wir den rahmen schwarz oder wir machen den
rahmen einfach immer grün wenn wir den rahmen nämlich immer grün machen sieht man es wahrscheinlich
immer ja aber das ist eine gute idee das machen wir hier schreibe ich mal auf to do wenn bild
dunkel dann rahmen weiß und weiß mit s oder mit ss oder mit sz oder mit das ist nicht
jolo das ist tensor flow light mit irgendeinem standard training set sz oder ss weiß farbe
weiß mit sz excellent wisst ihr wenn bild dunkel dann rahmen weiß und wenn bild hell
dann rahmen was sehr gut google größer du ne natürlich wo ist das das ist mein hoftor
das ist die webcam die ich aufgenommen habe hier die das ist der ausschnitt von meiner
webcam den ich zum testen aufgenommen habe komplementärfarbe ja sowas in der richtung
meine ich nämlich weil wisst ihr warum ich wie ich drauf kommen es gibt nämlich einen
neuen image sensor für home assistant 118 kam gestern raus image und da gibt es nämlich
einen neuen sensor und der ist genau für sowas da das hat mich auf die idee gebracht wie
heißt denn das hier macht den color code für person of interest das sagt mir jetzt nix
color extractor genau das meine ich predominant color die macht mir findet man sowas denn
raus das müsste ich ja dann das machen wir jetzt nicht das führt bisschen zu fern ab
da da müsste ich ja nämlich hier im eigentlichen objekt detektor da müsste ich hier gucken
weil hier habe ich das bild decoded am start und hier müsste ich gucken was ist die predominant
color oder ein browser das kann man doch bestimmt auch das kann man doch bestimmt auch im browser
machen oder klar war doch klar dass ein vorteil hat diese ganze javascript geschichte eine
sache ein vorteil hat diese ganze javascript geschichte es gibt einfach für alles irgendwas
ja also da kann man sich jetzt das ist halt das nice da dran ich weiß nicht wie man das
verwendet demo page click color palette das ist cool das ist cool jetzt ist nur die frage
geht das auch mit videos mit videoelementen jetzt zwar ein bisschen side tracked anscheinend
geht das noch nicht hier gibt es aber ein fork wo das geht du musstest letzten semester
durchschnittsfarben von bildblöcken berechnen ja zum glück müssen wir das nicht selbst
machen canvas image ich brauche kein canvas image ich brauche ein video da muss ich mich
mal da muss ich mich mal mit beschäftigen das kriegen wir relativ easy hin und es ist
auf jeden fall besser wenn wir das im browser machen als wenn wir das serverseitig machen
weil serverseitig läuft auf dem raspberry pi und ist eigentlich unnötig kompliziert
das dann auch zu machen das sollen die ruhig im browser machen kannst du nicht den keyframe
benutzen den du auch in der objekt detect ja meine ich ja das müsste ich dann hier
machen hier aber hier habe ich nämlich den hier habe ich die sache nämlich die coded
am start allerdings ist mein frame hier nicht rgb sondern juff 420p und ich glaube da wird
das noch schwieriger weil am besten machst du image machst du sowas in rgb weil die
meisten libraries rgb können ja ich mache das ich mache das ich mache das kleinseitig
im browser das auf jeden fall sinnvoller aber das muss ich mir mal muss ich mir mal speichern
und das können wir dann ausprobieren jupp ich speichere mir das mal ich muss gerade mal
die ganzen ollen tabs zu machen die ich hier noch offen habe so also wir machen jetzt erst
mal wir machen jetzt erst mal kümmern uns um die videoaufnahme das mal ein bisschen
weiter kommen aber das ist an sich eine coole idee wir können uns die library nehmen und
dann machen wir den block schwarz wenn es schwarz ist und weiß wenn es schwarz schwarzer
block wenn es hintergrund hell ist und ansonsten haben wir das umgedreht das ist eigentlich
cool wir invertieren das dann einfach immer ja das ist nice das probieren wir dann irgendwann
mal aus demnächst so also jetzt was wir heute machen ist folgendes die sache ist jetzt ja
die wenn der bewegung erkennt so hier jetzt er erkennt jetzt bewegung also dass hier irgendeine
person durchspiel läuft und prophecy ehrlich gesagt weiß ich das nicht kann durchaus sein
also in in juf hast ja mit dem letzten channel hast ja quasi ein graues rgb bild und das
bringt dir aber glaub nichts ganz ehrlich keine ahnung keine ahnung aber ich ich mache es
eh lieber kleinzeitig ich mache es eh lieber kleinzeitig da muss ich mich damit auf den
sofa gar nicht auseinandersetzen und es ist ja auch letztendlich eine rein kleinzeitige
geschichte wie ich hier diese rectangle rendere das darf ruhig kleinzeitig passieren darf
man einfach ein bisschen was arbeiten so also gehen wir mal hier zu das müssen wir uns
hier angucken also was wir heute machen ist folgendes der erkennt jetzt ja wenn bewegung
im bild ist und jetzt will ich aufnehmen wenn bewegung im bild ist 30 sekunden oder so ja
ich habe mich schon so ungefähr so ungefähr überlegt wie man das ganze machen könnten
ein bisschen zeugs hier zu machen weil ich auf dem anderen browser aufhabe also sagen
wir mal so wir machen das jetzt mal hier ganz primitiv erstmal in line in hier in in diesem
detected event weil ich einfach mal gucken will wie macht man das mit ffm pack eigentlich
gescheit dass das also ich weiß wie das geht ich habe auch was wo ich raus copy pasten kann
ich habe auch was wo ich raus copy pasten kann aber wobei kommen wir machen hier wir
machen hier neue neue datei ffm pack da haben wir schon kamerastream drin das helper zeug
drin da brauchen wir jetzt noch ein video file machen wir da jetzt noch rein so video
file und dann sagen wir hier video file und dann nehmen wir auf und dann mal gucken und
dann mal gucken output file mal gucken wie wir das machen also wie gesagt ich habe noch
ein altes projekt hier nebenbei auf wo ich ein bisschen abgucken kann wie man das ffm
pack mäßig macht weil ffm pack ist immer ein bisschen wissenschaft für sich deswegen
kann ich hier einfach schön abgucken ich muss es nur gerade finden wo ist es denn
es war getty jolognese kannst du machen ja mach mal leg los i will try to answer it so
capture capture service just service ich habe nämlich so was schon mal aufgenommen so was
in der richtung schon mal gemacht we love when he speaks english yes exquisite german
english accent so also wo habe ich es denn hier das passt genau da kann ich nämlich
ein bisschen bisschen abgucken also auf geht's video file so was brauchen wir da ich nur
mal so von der idee also ich will jetzt ja die wir machen das anders wir machen das
mal richtig nub style ich nehme einfach mal auf hier kriege ich ja die ganzen pakete
von der kamera yes just ask i will i will try my best so wir nehmen jetzt einfach mal
was auf hier also subscribe es so wir machen jetzt mal einen delay task die lehmung fällt
jetzt eigentlich nichts besseres ein zwei nach zwei sekunden nach zwei sekunden starten
wir mal eine aufnahme wobei nee nee nee moment was mache ich denn da nee das ergibt keinen
sinn ich muss anfangen aufzunehmen nee das aber ganz schöner crap das funktioniert
so nicht kann ich jetzt gar nicht einfach ausprobieren naja doch ich nehme einfach gleich auf so
bald er hier startet ich will einfach nur gucken ob ich das mit dem ob ich das ob ich
das hinbekomme in ffm pack zusammen kopiert weil das ist das schwierigste dass ich das
dass ich das video in ffm pack in der datei geschrieben bekomme die ich dann später mit
einem player aufmachen kann ok also was wollen wir denn haben so und jetzt sagen wir einfach
hier output file irgendwie right packet oder so denn einfach nur gucken dass ich irgendwas
da so public class void right und zwar ein packet so dann schreiben wir jetzt in der
datei und gucken ob sich mit einem player abspielen lässt das ist so der erste test
um zu schauen ob es überhaupt funktioniert was ich davor habe also das ding muss auf
jeden fall schon mal disposable sein kann ich schreiben weil wenn das nicht disposable
ist memory leak über garantiert und memory leaks wissen wir ja ist auf dauer nicht gerade
so schön so also können wir so wie bauen wir das ding denn jetzt auf also wir brauchen
auf jeden fall eine datei name wo wir hinschreiben wollen filename filename was was findet
ihr besser filename filename filename das sind so dinge über die mache ich mir viel
zu lange gedanken einfach irgendwas hinzuschreiben es ist komplett irrelevant wie es eigentlich
wirklich heißt jedes richtig gute programm hat memory leaks excellent ja so naja es ist
gar nicht mal so weit her geholt ich habe nämlich echt den eindruck dass viele gerade
kommerzielle software absichtlich kacke einbauen dass sie das in der nächsten version ausbessern
können fn soll ich denn mein könnnis wir können es auch einfach n n ne komm bursch
big feil big ne das mag ich nicht captain peng irgendwie habe ich damit noch nie warm
geworden mit mit dieser mit dieser bezeichnung für private und und sonstige sachen ich habe
da eh so einen merkwürdige vorliebe wo ganz gut ist dass ich das nicht im team programmieren
muss weil zum beispiel private sachen mache ich jetzt mittlerweile mit dem underscore davor
allerdings wenn ich jetzt sagen wir right hier aufrufen mache ich immer das davor ich
weiß ich ob es da irgendwie name für den style gibt aber ich mache es einfach so wie
es mir am besten gefällt so also wir brauchen auf jeden fall eine dateiname dass das funktioniert
so dann kann ich mir was kopieren dann brauchen wir ffm pack gedöns ohne ffm pack gedöns
können wir nicht schreiben in die datei einfach für jeden string wir könnten tatsächlich
du ebenso auf die idee ist gar nicht so schlecht man könnte wirklich anstatt den dateiname
eine random id generieren dann hat man nämlich auch gar keine mühe dass man was konfliktetes
kriegt weil ansonsten hast du ja das problem wie nenne ich die datei nenne ich die datei
wie den kameraname dann funktioniert es nicht timestamp alleine ist auch vielleicht nicht
ganz so schön vor allem nicht wenn man nur nur minuten genau macht also da müsst ihr
auf jeden fall schon mal rein kameraname der grund was diese aufnahme getriggert hat das
kann sein objekt also bewegungserkennung manuell auf den aufnahmeknopf gedrückt oder
irgendeine scheduler sache ok das brauche das brauchen wir auch noch also publik innum
nennen wir das etnum capture trigger so da haben wir ein manuel das ist wenn einer von
hand auf den aufnahmeknopf drücken jetzt die musik wieder so laut ne geht eigentlich
also wenn einer von hand auf den aufnahmeknopf drückt dann haben wir was wie motionerkennung
und wir haben timer sowas in der richtung also das sind ja so die drei sachen warum
eine aufnahme gestartet werden kann entweder es drückt einer von hand im webinterface auf
nehmen dann ist es manuel es ist der bewegungserkennung die macht das an dann motion oder halt irgendeine
zeitgestellte sache dann ist es ein timer ok das ist schon mal ja und man könnte man
könnte das echt mit einer random id machen das finde ich von der idee ja gar nicht so
schlecht das baue ich vielleicht gleich noch ein so also dann brauchen wir irgendwie sowas
wie wie in it oder so oder denn komm wir machen es mal wie diese dotnet file sachen publik
void open nennen wir das mal so und da müssen wir jetzt ffm pack zeug initialisieren drinne
da kann ich da kann ich schon mal was copy pasten
lustig heißt auch filename exzellent das da und save gespannt ob das funktioniert format
also ok das heißt der dateiname muss auf jeden fall sowas wie mp4 oder ts oder sowas
drinne haben weil ansonsten schlägt das hier fehl hier versucht er nämlich das beste format
für diesen für diese datei zu erkennen das heißt ich muss auf jeden fall eine endung
vergeben wo man irgendwas schlüssiges sich draus ableiten kann so dann brauchen wir
einen neuen ja so dann brauchen wir einen neuen was auch immer format kontext das braucht
man ffm pack um sachen in der datei zu ffm pack braucht für alles irgendwelche kontexte
das ist so absolut nicht sagen immer so den brauchen wir da können wir meinen erst mal
testen ob das funktioniert das heißt wenn das nämlich fehl schlägt aus irgendwelchen
gründen dann returnen wir falls wir sollten ja schon checken ob das überhaupt funktioniert
vielleicht krascht ja das ffm pack irgendwie oder es kann das format nicht oder sowas und
hier unten ist true so wir öffnen die datei dann machen wir noch
schreiben das da oben rein dass ich das so später wieder auf also gut genau weil die
sache ist die hier lege ich das an für ffm pack ffm pack ist unmanaged das heißt ich
muss die sachen spätestens bei dispose wieder wieder auf wieder freen wieder freen so das
heißt dann gucken wir mal dass ich sage hier ffm pack av format dann close close genau
ach nee ach nee das geht ja nicht wie war das fixed tmp wieso excellent ja ach so public
unsafe ok so der räumt jetzt automatisch für mich auf zumindest wenn ich in using davor
haue so jetzt müssen wir den kram in die datei
reinschreiben als ich mein objekt erkennung funktioniert immer noch es ist so spät leute
ich kann ich mir richtig gut denken wir machen jetzt dieses wir machen diese eine sache jetzt
hier noch ist aber zu spät heute ich kann bin ich ja immer so fit also jetzt brauchen
wir den neuen stream also was wir jetzt hier machen ist wir sagen ffm pack wir möchten
die datei öffnen und wir möchten die datei öffnen und in diese datei schreiben wir dann
sachen aus diesem aus diesem webcam zeug rein sobald also sobald die bewegungserkennung
eine person erkennt starten wir sage ich meine 30 sekunden aufnahme und was ich vorhabe ist
dass der zehn sekunden rückwärts aufnimmt das wird auch noch mal big brain bis das funktioniert
ich will dass er immer buffert permanent dass er immer zehn sekunden buffert und sobald
er dann bewegungserkennung macht schreibt er die zehn sekunden vom buffer in der datei
und ab dann nimmt er weiter auf das hat nämlich den vorteil dass wenn die bewegungserkennung
greift das ist gerade einer durchs bild gerannt dann ist die aufnahme trotzdem drauf und es
kostet keine zusätzliche leistung großartig das zu buffern ok wir brauchen neuen stream
ok jetzt brauche ich die parameter für den stream ok das wird das wird das wird sackig
wo kriege ich denn die her als ich brauche auf jeden fall hier oben dann ein rapper den
ich gebaut habe genau händler und ich brauche eine timebase timebase ist im prinzip so was
wie die fps von dem video da musst du eine ringliste nutzen habe ich jetzt gelernt ja
man kann aber auch einfach eine stink normale queue verwenden und und immer ein element hinten
rein machen und eins vorne die queue oder funktioniert doch genauso warum soll ich mich
um irgendwelche index elemente und buffer gedöns kümmern natürlich ist die reine
leere wahrscheinlich in den ring buffer oder so ja ok also ich bekomme das jetzt übergeben
das heißt ich kann das jetzt da rein kopieren die parameter copy oder sowas genau das ist
was ist ein source hier das ist destination also in parameters steht bei ffm pack zum
beispiel hier sowas drin ich zeige es euch mal da steht drin was das ding für eine bitrate
hat was für einen codec verwendet und das muss ich vom output gerät also von der kamera
kopieren weil ansonsten müsste ich irgendwas raten und am besten ist ich kopiere das von
der kamera mit ist das kompatibel mit einem output file format dann funktioniert alles
wenn ich schmeißen fehler aber nachdem wir nur h264 encode des streams unterstützen sollte
das eigentlich passen so get zack so copy dann kann ich mir so was kopieren excellent
oder kann ich mir trauen leute das hier das muss man setzen sonst funktioniert es nicht
das ist richtig fail da habe ich mal einen tag darum gewusstet bis das funktioniert hat
die st aus irgendwelchen gründen kann ffm pack die datei sonst nicht schreiben man muss
codec tag 0 setzen wenn man nicht codec tag 0 setzt schmeißt der random irgendwelche
sinnlosen fehler ich weiß bis heute nicht warum was das bedeutet warum man das braucht
aber man braucht sonst geht es nicht so jetzt müssen wir die datei öffnen also das schreibe
ich ab das weiß ich nicht aus dem kopf das schreibe ich ab open 2 so das öffnet jetzt
die datei und legt die datei an das heißt wenn wir das jetzt gemacht haben dann müsste
er schon mal hier auf dem file system eine datei erstellen die so heißt wie ich ihm übergeben
habe was hat mir dank problem den neuen smart router der telekom kaufen dürfen jetzt funktioniert
die tp link verbindung zum medialisier vernichtet das ist ja schwierig das kann man jetzt wirklich
schwierig beantworten man weiß ja überhaupt nicht was du verwendest in welcher kombination
welche technik dahinter ist und alles das ist jetzt echt schwierig zu sagen so also
jetzt müssen wir die datei öffnen also immer file name und jetzt das das nächste kopier
ich jetzt einfach weil exzellent ffmpeg magic keine ahnung was es bedeutet so genau
13 sagt auch im chat grad hab auch mal eine stunde habe auch mal schon dran gehängt weil
ich einem debus aufruf debus ist auch so ein ding er hat eine null mitgegeben hat anstatt
einem in 64 mit dem werden ja so dinger sind teilweise echt lustig suchst du die ich ewig
suchst du ewig einen ab und in wirklichkeit hast du alles richtig gemacht außer an einer
stelle verkackt oder oder die doku von denen stimmt nicht oder oder was auch immer so jetzt
gucken wir ob die datei geöffnet werden konnte wir machen jetzt noch einmal drum herum also
wenn das nicht funktioniert wenn das nicht geht mit dem öffnen wenn das nicht geht mit
dem öffnen dann sagen wir return falls weil wir können das einfach so machen weil das
sieht jetzt schon ganz schön hässlich aus oder ihr lasst das mal so so also wenn er
die datei nicht öffnen konnte dann geben wir falls zurück jetzt müssen jetzt jetzt
oh ach du scheiße jetzt kommt big brain da weiß ich beim besten will nicht was es bedeutet
habe ich bestimmt mal irgendwo her copy paste passt mal auf big brain code des of doom hier
ich habe keine ahnung ah yes alles klar alles klar ich kann mich ich krieg so ungefähr
zusammen was das macht kill fill was ist und ctx bp das ist big brain benahmung von mir
das ist der ffm pack kontext ffm pack nennt alles irgendwie kontext also ctx ist dieses
ding was hier am anfang anlege wenn man die da wenn man um output zu schreiben das heißt
halt so das hier ist eigentlich sollte ich vielleicht so schreiben weiß nicht ob das
besser ist dann erkennt man sich also das hier ist der kontext das ist ein pointer das
ist ein pointer auf hier bp für was auch immer das steht es ist es ist ffm pack logisch
logisch also sprich ctx ist ist ein struct in den ffm pack struct mit einem member bp
drinnen und das ist ein zeiger zeiger auf bp in kontext und davon dann die adresse genommen
also sprich zeiger auf bp und dann hier die adresse von bp deswegen habe ich jetzt die
klammern drum rum gemacht dann erkennt man es besser also das ist unsav schaab sieht
man auch hier das funktioniert nur wenn der unsav setzt ansonsten ist hier mit pointer
und gedöns nix hast du eigentlich auch kontakt zum kaboom ab und zu ja wir können ja mal
nachgucken was das ist man muss nämlich sagen die ffm pack doku ist gar nicht so schlecht
was macht unsav unsav sorgt dafür dass du pointer und adresse operator verwenden darfst
das ist das einzige du darfst pointer nehmen also raw pointer und du kannst adresse und
du darfst adressen auslesen das ist zum größten teil alles was unsav macht allerdings sagen
die halt auch dabei wenn du unsav code verwendest dann kannst du dir halt selbst ins knie schießen
ja was ich auch schon oft genug da aus versehen gemacht habe so gucken wir uns mal an was
das ist bp also bp sagt alter ffm pack alles klar ja alles klar super exquisite doke kürze
kennst du system back für ubuntu nö also bp ist ein io kontext warum es bp heißt erschließt
ich mir nicht die maxing maxing ok es ist irgendeinen kontext den man braucht um das
video in den in den output container von der datei zu schreiben was auch immer man muss
es so machen sonst funktioniert nicht ich kann dir gar nicht genau erklären warum ich
kopiere das auch nur aus einer sache von der ich weiß dass es geht ja und diese dinge
hier sind hier absolut schwarze magie ich kann euch ungefähr ungefähr ungefähr versuchen
zu erklären was das was es macht also wir nehmen mp4 datei mp4 ist ja ein container und
mp4 hat die eigenschaft dass sie am ende der datei erst schreiben wie lang das video in
der datei ist das bedeutet wenn die aufnahme ab bricht und die datei nicht richtig beendet
wird ist eine mp4 also ist die mp4 als container verwenden nicht mehr lesbar so ohne weiteres
so und wenn man hier diese diese flex angibt die was auch immer machen sorgt dafür dass
die mp4 datei diese sachen am anfang schreibt oder nach jedem frame oder sowas und auch
eine korrupte mp4 datei lesbar ist man könnte übrigens einfach anstatt mp4 einfach ts verwenden
hätte die probleme alle nicht also eigentlich bescheuert warum nehme ich eigentlich mp4
warum nehme ich noch mal mp4 ich weiß nicht wir können einfach ts nehmen hat man die
probleme nicht ja und das ist irgendein magic dings das habe ich mal irgendwo auf stack
overflow gefunden das habe ich garantiert garantiert auf stack overflow gefunden bestimmt
stack overflow habe ich das garantiert so dann schreibt er den mp4 header in die datei
ist der ist nicht typescript nein das könnte auch transport stream sein aber es könnte
auch typescript sein so dann schreibt er den mp4 header in die datei und freet dieses
dictionary weil sonst memory leak und dann merken wir uns noch mal ob die datei offen
ist wenn man irgendwie type bool ist open oder sowas da ist die das übrigens das ist
auch eine sache die braucht man nicht bool ist standardmäßig falls aber ich finde es
schöner wenn die sachen standardmäßig belegt sind so dass man noch mal klar ist ah standardmäßig
ist falls brauchen wir nicht ok das haben wir das open gleich gleich true true 0w meine
kamera gibt kein mp4 zurück meine kamera gibt in h264 stream aus über rtsp das hat mit
mp4 gar nichts zu tun mp4 ist bloß das container format in der datei später also in so einem
container steht zum beispiel drin ob es untertitel gibt welche audiospuren welche videospuren
welche soundspuren wie lang das video ist wann keyframes kommen und solche dinger stehen
im container drin wobei die keyframes stehen glaube ich nicht drin ja das braucht man zum
beispiel dass man ein video spulen kann und sowas das ist ja bei einem stream egal so
und jetzt schreiben wir hier die die packets rein so das war folgendermaßen so wir gucken
jetzt wir machen sogar mal ein bisschen fehlerbehandlung fast big brain fehlerbehandlung ist also wenn
es nicht geöffnet ist die datei also mal angenommen das hier schlägt fehl open schlägt
fehl und ich schreibe dann trotzdem was in die datei da kann das natürlich nicht funktionieren
deswegen sagen wir wenn die datei nicht geöffnet ist machen wir eine new exception gibt es
was besseres als eine i o exception feil exception oder sowas feil load exception i o exception
ist schon ok i o exception und sagen da irgendwie sowas right before open open so was und da
schreiben wir jetzt rein feil name excellent so ist open so und jetzt müssen wir die jetzt
müssen wir die pakete schreiben also war packet war packet gleich also mein packet habe ich
jetzt zweimal right packet what the fuck ah was mache ich denn da ich bin ja gar nicht
hier drinnen lol packet gleich raw ffmpeg pointer gedünns und es muss unsafe sein sonst
funktioniert das ganze nicht so und da schreiben wir jetzt in die datei würde ich sagen also
sagen wir ffmpeg right ne av right hier av right frame und zwar mit diesem kontext dieses
dieses packet will ich schreiben so und jetzt auch eine sache die ich in der vergangenheit
öfter schon verkackt habe jedes paket von so einem live stream hatten ein timestamp
eigentlich immer genau sie haben die zwei timestamps also die pakete haben zwei timestamps die
haben dts und die haben pts das ist der die coding timestamp das ist das ist wirklich
absolut hier next level shit was ich audio video leute ausgedacht haben das kann man
auch nur zur kenntnis nehmen und nicht und nicht hundertprozentig verstehen also es gibt
ein die coding timestamp und es gibt ein presentation timestamp das heißt das hier sagt dem decoder
in welcher reinfolge die pakete die coded werden müssen und der pts sagt irgendwas
was die video frames rendern will in welcher reinfolge die frames gerendert werden sollen
dementsprechend heißt es auch pts kann nie kleiner als dts sein weil ich kann ja schlecht
was anzeigen bevor es decoded wurde so und nachdem ich viel zu lowprane bin timestamps
richtig ordentlich zu berechnen mache ich das eigentlich mache ich das so dass ich dts
und pts immer auf den gleichen wert setze der hochgezählt wird man kann es nicht einfach
in die datei schreiben man kann es nicht man kann es nicht das gibt es bei kommunikationstechnik
ja gut das gibt es weil der audio video übertragen wird so was soll ich jetzt sagen ja also man
kann es nicht einfach nehmen wie es ist weil da stehen ja die timestamps vom stream der
kamera aktuell drinne und kameras stream timestamps funktionieren da nicht in meiner datei meine
datei müssen die timestamps von null anfangen und die kameras streams fangen über 50 billionen
an oder so was auch immer gerade aktuelle camera timestamps ist deswegen brauchen wir
noch ein timestamp ich kopiere mir das mal hier deswegen brauchen wir noch sowas hier
current timestamp und das machen wir jetzt ganz ganz simpel so dass es zu 99 prozent
funktioniert manche videos haben damit vielleicht probleme aber ganz ehrlich erstmal drauf
geschissen weiß gar nicht ob das so eine gute idee ist das hier drin anzupassen ne wisst
ihr was wir machen wir machen das anders wir machen das anders ich will das nicht ändern
das package weil das kann sein dass das noch andere verwenden wir machen ffm pack av clone
package clone packet und da übergeben wir das jetzt jetzt behälter der kopiert nicht
das paket auch wenn sich das hier so liest der kopiert nur die metadata und referenziert
den gleichen buffer also da wird nichts großartiges kopiert das ist relativ performant das ganze
so dts ist das ist timestamp ist timestamp so und jetzt zählen wir das ganze hoch und
jetzt sagen wir ihm hier nachdem er das geschrieben hat currents timestamp ist plus gleich duration
fertig ob das funktioniert oder wir können sogar package packet duration ist eigentlich
egal oder auch nicht duration duration also so ein timestamp folgt irgendwie einer internen
logik die sich zusammensetzt aus fps des videos in der timebase mcoding rate keine ahnung
ganz ehrlich das rechnet ffm pack für mich aus das muss ich nicht selbst machen so jetzt
schreiben wir den des in die datei und dann ist eigentlich gut da können wir gucken ob
es funktioniert ich muss jetzt nur noch schauen dass der alles richtig schließt also wenn
die datei disposed wird und wenn sie wenn sie gestartet war also wenn wenn da sachen
reingeschrieben wurden dann müssen wir nämlich noch sagen dass er noch den container fertig
schreibt right trailer so chat und wenn ich jetzt alles richtig gemacht habe sollte ich
jetzt zeug in der datei schreiben können schauen wir mal video fallen wir brauchen da teilnahme
plupp punkt mp4 plupp punkt mp4 also wir schreiben einfach blind irgendwas rein output file
right nein output file right können wir nicht machen wir müssen machen output file open
ah miss da brauche ich jetzt die parameter monachs wo kriege ich die parameter her aus
so einem paket ok wir machen das jetzt richtig eklig aber ich will einfach nur gucken ob
es funktioniert also if output file open wenn es nicht open ist dann machen wir output file
open excellent und da gehen wir jetzt rein paket product parameters und paket timebase
so und dann schreiben wir was in die datei rein fusing moment fusing was hat er für schmerzen
das kann funktionieren das muss ich anders machen das darf ich nicht hier disposen ich
muss sagen wenn der stream vorbei ist dann sage ich output file close das problem ist
das ist ja nie vorbei ok wir gucken einfach mal funktioniert einfach mal schauen ob es
klappt ob das jetzt aufnimmt ok wir erstmal in das in das repo gucken ob es jetzt eine
datei geben die plupp punkt mp4 heißt gibt es nicht ah alter ich bin ja auch doof noch
if not open dann open wir was macht using using sorgt dafür dass am ende dieses blockes
automatisch die aufräumen das am ende des blockes wenn es aus dem scope geht automatisch
die aufräumen metode aufgerufen wird macht memory management ein bisschen einfacher
wohlgemerkt das braucht man normalerweise gar nicht normalerweise wenn man alles managt
macht und nix unsafe dann macht der garbage collector das für dich das ist kein problem
aber nachdem ich hier unmanaged Sachen drinne habe die ich selbst freigeben will brauche
ich sowas man kann auch nur destructor machen der das für einen aufrufen soll aber ich
finde es mit disposed schöner zu sehen ok gibt es jetzt eine datei plupp punkt mp4
ja leute gibts da die datei die falsche farbe plupp punkt mp4 so plupp und guck mal die
nimmt auch immer weiter auf das problem ist nur ich kann das nicht stoppen ich hab nix
zum stoppen weil eigentlich will ich das gar nicht hier drinne machen einfach nur
zum ausprobieren aber wisst ihr was wenn ichs richtig gemacht hab kann ich die datei
abspielen obwohl es noch läuft weil ich hab ja hier oben diese parameter gesetzt selbst
wenn die datei abbricht das können wir gleich mal probieren ob das funktioniert selbst
wenn die aufnahme nicht richtig beendet wird ist die datei nicht korrupt das probieren
wir jetzt aus einfach abbrechen und jetzt gucken wir ob wir es abspielen können also
wir haben 14 14 mb es kommt erst was ff probe sagt ff probe sagt es ist es ist ein h264
stream in mp4 und das ganze ist eine minute 39 das sieht schon mal gut aus das sieht schon
mal gut aus also ff play plupp was ist da unten easy funktioniert poggers aufnahme geht easy
easy easy as fuck so das ist doch gut datei also auf nähe aufnahme von dem video stream
aus dem browser funktioniert schon mal ok das war einfach wie zuverlässig das funktioniert
muss ich noch zeigen ok jetzt ist ja hier aber 33 sekunden 34 sekunden funktioniert
läuft auch flüssig sind auch keine getrobten frames drin oder sonst was ich mein was natürlich
in der aufnahme nicht drinne ist ist hier die object detection dass da eine person ist und
so weil die person ist ja ein overlay das ist ja ein overlay über einem browser und
ist natürlich in der aufnahme nicht drin da war ein geist fast ist ja gar nicht geflogen
ok das funktioniert excellent ok also die basics funktionieren schon mal jetzt kann
ich das alles wieder löschen weil hier hier drinne soll das ja gar nicht verwendet werden
das war ja so zum testen ob das aufnehmen prinzipiell funktioniert gut und jetzt habe
ich noch eine stunde zeit das ordentlich einzubauen was hat er für schmerzen wo wo wo lector awaits
lector hier awaits hier lector awaits also wie machen wir das denn jetzt mal schön ich würde
sagen wir machen da jetzt also wir haben ja schon mal ein object detection service wir machen jetzt
einen captures capture capture background service oder irgendwie sowas capture service
so der background service background service background service das heißt im endeffekt
nichts anderes wie dass die runtime sich drum kümmern wann das ding gestartet und
gestoppt wird das heißt muss ich nicht selbst machen was heißt die runtime die benachrichtigt
die runtime oder asp benachrichtigt mich wenn es beendet wird so da müssen wir das hier noch
irgendwo registrieren dass es funktioniert also hier services ads hosted service und zwar jetzt
einen background ne ne ne ein ein ein capture capture was ist ein schöner capture oder recording
service ich nenne es capture capture ich mag record ich mag das wort recording und record
und so das ist so doppelt und dreifach deutlich das capture service ist schöner ctf service
passt ja nicht so ganz so also also was was war das mit lass mal kurz abgucken ob ich
irgendwas hab was ich dann auch verwerten kann capture service also wir machen erste mal auf
jeden fall den constructor und injecten mal ein paar sachen nämlich wir brauchen auf jeden fall
den message bus dass ich mit bekomme wenn ich sachen aufnehmen soll so dann brauchen wir auf
jeden fall in den logger dass ich ein bisschen output machen kann so capture the frame das ist
sogar eigentlich richtig gut ist wahrscheinlich wirklich das muss man echt so nennen so dann
brauchen wir was brauchen sonst noch ein logger und das war es erst mal das was erst mal dabei
gut sein zack read only field read only field hallo hä was hat er denn eben gemacht
ich habe dann dings davor gemacht bin ja auch doof ok so so das heißt jetzt müssen wir gucken wir
machen den constructor mal oben drüber dann findet man den besser so jetzt müssen wir erst mal
schauen wenn das gestartet wird wir müssen uns dieses token merken irgendwie shutdown token
also es ist so wenn ich das programm beende dann kriege ich hier einen signal geschickt mit so nach
dem motto beende mal alle aufnahmen das muss ich mir merken weil wenn ich mir das nicht merke dann
schießt mich die runtime irgendwann ab und das muss ja nicht sein ich will ja alle aufnahmen
ordnungsgemäß benden das heißt ich muss mir das merken und wenn wenn das auf stoppt oder auf cancel
geht muss ich alle aufnahmen beenden und mich beenden und ich glaube ich glaube ich habe fünf
sekunden zeit dafür danach wird glaube ich meinen thread abgeschossen wenn ich das nicht mache wenn
ich mich recht entsinne ich bin mir dann bei den timings nicht ganz sicher ok also was muss ich
jetzt mitbekommen ich muss mitbekommen wenn jemand sagt ich möchte aufnehmen also subscribe und zwar
ach so da brauchen wir erst mal eine message die ich mit mit bekomme wo habe ich denn das war habe
ich das gemacht das ist was was was selbstgestricktes also ich habe nämlich diese reactive extensions
für mich entdeckt hat mir gedacht ich muss mal ein bisschen rumbasteln mit reactive extensions
also wir brauchen erst mal eine message also was haben wir denn wir haben also wir haben eine message
für detection result das ist wenn der wenn der motion wenn das objekt detection was detected hat
also hier eine person oder so dann haben wir das eine camera stream gestartet wurde in event so das
heißt wir brauchen im endeffekt noch sowas wie einen kopieren das jetzt einfach mal wir brauchen
auch sowas wie einen capture capture start request message oder sowas so capture start request
message weiß ich noch nicht was ich da brauche die kamera kamera kamera und genau den was was
ich auch mit also was es für einen aufnahmetyp ist also sprich ob das manuelle aufnahme ist
ein timer aufnahme das brauche ich auf jeden fall so und dann brauchen wir das ganze noch capture
capture stop request oder sowas ok so jetzt müssen wir uns noch überlegen wie wir das
ganze triggern können ich würde sagen über einen curl aufruf zum testen also stellvertretend für
den web client machen wir das mal über den curl aufruf haben wir schon einen für cancel zum
testen dann machen wir noch ein rekord rekord aufruf das ist auch nur temporär bis ich das mal
alles in die datenbank schreibe so und jetzt sagen wir publish und zwar publishen wir jetzt eine wie
habe wir habe ich dann capture capture start request das ist das können fast in java das
können fast in java eine name sein oder capture start request das wobei in java wird es bräuchte
man dann noch eine capture start request message factory service der das für einen anlegt das
geht ja nicht einfach so kamera ist das und trigger ist ja gut kommt halt drauf an wir sagen
weil wir tun mal so wir tun mal so als wäre es was von der von der object detection also wir tun
jetzt mal so als wäre hier was erkannt worden und er sagt jetzt bitte aufnehmen noch eine factory
ja mindestens eine ich würde sagen wir brauchen noch einen factory service factory service generator
brauchen wir noch ist noch zu wenig engine manager manager brauchen wir auch noch
factory capture start request message factory service engine manager dass
ist fassad genau observable observable observable factory manager so gut jetzt wird
er immer besser implementation implement impel impel ist so schön z plus plus kacke noch ein
impel concrete frame capture factory service manager engine so machen wir das oder alternativ
lassen wir es einfach so und lassen es lesbar so also wir starten jetzt hier dann also wir
schicken jetzt hier eine message bitte aufnahme starten das heißt hier subscriben wir auf diese
message wenn die reinkommt ups hier subscriben wir auf die message wenn die reinkommt jetzt
brauchen wir in den also wir haben jetzt die wahl entweder machen wir das in line wir machen das
nicht in line das wird sonst zu lang ich weiß jetzt schon dass das viel zu viel zu lang und
eklig wird deswegen sagen wir hier private void handle start requests und er kriegt eine
message übergeben das nehme ich hier drin so sollten wir es nennen ja so und nicht anders
also händel start request das kann man ja alles noch bisher richtig lesen das ist schon mal nicht
java style auf jeden fall so capture start message listen ich drauf und dann listen ich auf capture
stop message so und das kommt hier mal aus weil habe ich keine methode für so das heißt wenn
ich eine anfrage bekomme das machen wir dann irgendwie über karl in karl aufruf für karl
immer karl localhost 5000 slash camera slash record ok ok ok also es gibt schon mal kein
fehler das heißt ich sollte jetzt zumindest jetzt jemand output bekommen wenn ich das abschicke
das karl wenn das alles funktioniert aha ist exzellent ane moment ob man den job program mit
ausführen repeat ich will mal gucken wie viel wie viel ich das ist repeat 5 ich bin ich bin
dazu low brain für doch jetzt hier repeat ohne ohne quotes ok repeat repeat 1000 also das verursacht
nicht mal großartig cpu last das terminal verursacht cpu last also wir kriegen auf jeden
fall die message dass wir starten wollen gut das heißt wir kopieren uns mal die camera
raus hier die brauchen auf jeden fall öfters die camera von der wir aufnehmen und den trigger
den brauchen wir auch garantiert nämlich das was das ausgelöst hat die aufnahme so und jetzt
haben wir schon ein problem ich habe doch gesagt ich will rückwirkend aufnehmen das heißt ich
muss hier irgendwie waffern sobald das stream zu einer camera gestartet wird ja
warte mal ich hab doch hier eine camera startet event das können wir doch da einfach
subscriben ist jetzt richtig c camera startet message jeder machen wir das doch einfach mal
also das hier capture camera startet message dann brauchen wir irgendwie ein händel händel
start oder so camera start und der kriegt die message hier und da müssen wir ihm jetzt
irgendwie sagen dass der unendlich lang quasi bis man die camera mal stoppt immer in zehn
sekunden buffer mitlaufen lässt also also wenn die camera startet da müsste ich jetzt hier
warte mal so da müsste ich jetzt hier direkt am starten output kriegen
hier guckt da camera ist gestartet ich krieg ich krieg's mit ok alles klar kann man bei den trigger
nicht buffer sein und nach motion das hinzu was das habe ich net kapiert so output so hier kriege
ich hier kriege ich die camera bild hier kriege ich die einzelnen bilder von der camera raus das
kommt hierher guckt hier kommt das her ich mache das mal kurz weg das brauchen wir nämlich alles
nicht mehr hier das ist relativ übersichtlich also die camera wirft ein event wenn es neuen frame
gibt was macht gut wenn es neuen frame gibt wirft die camera ein event und hier fängt er das event
ab und macht so einen reactive observable drauf das habe ich erst gestern so eingebaut weil ich
gerade wie gesagt diese reactive extension eigentlich ganz cool finde so das heißt ich
bekomme jetzt hier meine ganzen frames ich glaube es ist big brain time ich muss gerade mal was
nachgucken weil ich habe so was vorhin schon mal ausprobiert also wie gesagt ich mache das ich das
ist jetzt kann nicht komplett blind oder so ich habe vorhin schon ein bisschen rumprobiert also
wo habe ich es denn ich habe mir nämlich vorhin schon was überlegt jetzt kommt ihr passbar auf
leute jetzt kommt exploding exploding brain time was das wird das wird einmal was wo du
deine camera in den oder deine überwachungs camera oder was auch immer irgendwas was 264 input hat
kannst du in deinen browser streamen und dann kannst du erkennen ob es dort personen im bild
gibt und wenn es personen im bild gibt dann kannst du aufnehmen allerdings zehn sekunden
rückwirkend damit du nichts verpasst das mit dem aufnehmen bastel ich gerade so also output
passbar auf jetzt ist jetzt kommt wirklich big brain time also so ich bin mir noch nicht ganz
sicher ob das so eine ob das so eine gute idee ist ob das nicht irgendwelche nebenwirkung hat
von denen von denen ich noch nichts mitgekriegt habe das müssen wir gleich mal ausprobieren
jetzt habe ich komplett falsch geschrieben so einfachen array als ring buffer ich habe
mich schon überlegt ob ich nicht sowas hier nehme ob ich sowas hier nehme das wäre die
das wäre die easy variante so dem concurrent q und dann sage ich immer dann sage ich immer
einmal die q und einmal nq mit was neuem und dann habe ich immer so einen so einen buffer
von frag mich nicht zehn sekunden oder so da muss ich nur mal ausrechnen aus der package duration
wie lang sein muss greifst du für die objekt erkennung auf library zu ja da ist unter der
haube also ich mache es über den web request an was was schon fertig ist was ich einfach
nur starten muss unter der haube ist das tensor flow mit tensor flow lite mit irgendeiner keine
ahnung trainings datenbank mit ganz vielen leuten drin also keine lex das ist merkwürdig wenn
du uns erklärst was ist was du genau einsetzt können wir dir vielleicht helfen aber so war
das habe ich vorhin nicht nicht kapiert soll wir machen ist big brain time also ich habe
sie mit fünf angehörig code pass mal da habe ich nämlich vorhin bei den reactive extensions
gefunden man kann jetzt sagen also hier aus diesem output ihr seht kommt ganz viele av packages
raus av packages ist das was meine kamera generiert meine kamera generiert av packages ganz viele
unendlich lange so lange bis die kamera verreckt irgendwann mal generiert es av packages so und
nee ich bin falsch wo muss ich hin und ich habe vorhin bei den reactive extensions was
gefunden wo man wo wir jetzt wirklich echt massive big brain time machen können replay
output wie gesagt habe ich mir nicht jetzt on the fly ausgedacht das habe ich vorhin schon
vorhin schon gesehen replay output replay so und replay ist eine funktion in den reactive extensions
also wer sich fragt was ist das ist es die scharplein gibt es übrigens für viele sprachen das
ist eine library von microsoft relativ beliebt auf github die die erlaubt mit streams einfacher
zu arbeiten und mit streams halt alles ist halt alles gemeint was irgendeinen anfang hat und
dann daten kontinuierlich streams what are you doing i can try to explain
need to start a program i try to capture the streams from my cameras this is an example
example camera footage it's not live it's captured from one of my cameras and it will
analyze if some person walks through postchamp postchamp postchamp it sends every every keyframe
to an object detection service not in the clouds only offline and sends to the browser client
where it has detected some persons and draws this rectangle and if it has detected motion
or some objects it will try to record the footage to a file with 10 seconds time shift
buffer backwards in time so so if it triggers if a person walks through if it triggers it
will record 10 seconds back and from now for 30 seconds das ist das was ich probiere excellent
code documents itself yes wir wissen alle guter guter code document jetzt nicht selbst so also
es wird zeit für big brain code was ich gesagt also man kann mit den reactive extensions kann man
sagen replay so und replay macht jetzt folgendes ich mal gucken ob man da halt eine hilfe zu
anzeigen lassen kann also das ist ja mal wieder hier big brain also wer das versteht was die
hier schreiben das ist dann weiß ich auch nicht return to connect was so observable sequence also
was es macht ist im prinzip man kann eine zeitspanne angeben dann wird es wahrscheinlich auch
deutlicher man kann eine zeitspanne angeben und der buffert für mich jetzt genau 10 sekunden lang
diesen output und ich muss das nicht selbst machen ich muss einfach nur sagen output replay so und
was jetzt passiert der macht quasi so einen ring buffer intern für elf sekunden überschreibt
dann immer wieder und irgendwann kann ich mich dran attachen und sobald ich mich attache oder
connecte bekomme ich die letzten elf sekunden aus diesem buffer instant zugeschickt und ab
dann immer in echtzeit sobald die pakete reinkommen also eigentlich ist es richtig geil dieses zeug
wie gesagt da bin ich jetzt nicht on the fly drauf gekommen das habe ich mir vorhin
eingeguckt soll jetzt kann man nicht sagen replay connect und ab jetzt fängt er an zu
buffern also sprich der buffert jetzt kontinuierlich elf sekunden lang und wenn er bei elf sekunden
angelangt ist dann überschreibt er den anfang wieder das heißt er hat immer so eine heisst
auch window immer so ein zeitfenster von elf sekunden wo er den output von der kamera aufzeichnet
das heißt wenn ich jetzt eine aufnahme starte dann kann ich elf sekunden rückwärts reinschreiben
und bekomme ab dann echtzeit die sachen das heißt ich muss mich überhaupt gar nicht selbst
irgendwie um buffer management kümmern was echt nice ist ich bin mir halt noch nicht sicher ob
das nicht irgendwelche nebenwirkungen hat ja also zum beispiel dass es sich nicht richtig close und
nicht sich memory leaks haben oder so keine ahnung ich habe mit reactive extensions vorher noch so
gut wie gar nichts gemacht aber hierfür für kameras streams und streams allgemein ist das wirklich
echt nice das ist aber auch wie gemacht dafür fulltime streamer max ist zu feifert zu viel
zeit für vorbereitung wenigstens ging mir jetzt was gebacken ok jetzt muss ich mal überlegen jetzt
jetzt habe ich einen buffer von bis zu elf sekunden von meiner kamera jetzt muss ich irgendwie mit
bekommen wenn jemand sagt bitte aufnehmen das heißt ich muss hier eine buffer liste oder
irgendwas anlegen mit diesen buffern drin dass ich da später drauf zugreifen kann also machen
was hier private read only concurrent dictionary bestehend aus der id von der kamera und diesem
buffer die sind buffer da so buffers verletzt hat gar nichts anders aber wir können es wir
können es so wie es im tv ist timeshift buffers nennen oh ja so
jetzt einfach programme komplett neu easy alles in f-sharp am besten gleich noch so
und jetzt schreiben wir das hier rein also timeshift buffers push nicht ja was gibt
die kamera all die weil ich will ja nur ein buffer pro kamera starten 50 dinger starten
also drei ads all die und jetzt hier das replay rein replay ist ja eigentlich mein buffer also
warum ich das replay genannt habe soll ich besser buffern so buffer gut so und jetzt schreibe ich
unendlich lang immer elf sekunden lang in diesen buffer rein und dann immer wieder von vorne und
immer im kreis gut jetzt kann ich sagen wenn ein request kommt dass ich etwas aufnehmen soll bin
ich zu low praying gerade wenn ein request kommt dass ich was aufnehmen soll dann hole ich mir den
buffer raus und schreibe zehn sekunden einfach in der datei so timeshift buffers was machen wir
jetzt drei drei get oder so zwei ja irgendwie so drei drei nicht drei get gibt es also was hier
get zwei get also wenn es für diese also wenn ich der anfrage bekomme zum beispiel ich soll
kamera null aufnehmen da muss ich gucken okay gibt mir mal den buffer wo die letzten elf
sekunden footage von der kamera und dann schreibe ich die in der datei ab da nehme ich einfach
kontinuierlich auf ok das das klingt doch eigentlich das klingt doch eigentlich erst mal
sinnvoll also kamera all die out war excellent ok übrigens wenn das nicht funktioniert dann
was hat er für schmerzen warum ist das redundant aber wahrscheinlich weil ich schon nichts danach
gemacht habe ok jetzt muss ich mal kurz in mich gehen muss ich jetzt machen ich muss jetzt erst
mal ok wir schreiben wir schreiben jetzt einfach mal was in die datei wir probieren jetzt mal
ob das funktioniert mit dem rückwärts mit dem rückwärts aufnehmen also new video file das
funktioniert jetzt nur genau einmal danach geht es kaputt aber erst mal so datei plupp punkt mp4
wie sie einfach zehn minuten in liste stand was meinst du so feil so jetzt brauchen wir
open und jetzt sagen wir mal wir warten auf den buffer post ok also wir warten jetzt bis
das erste paket in diesem buffer reinkommt was ja schon drin sein sollte so dann sagen wir wir
wollen aus diesem paket die codec parameter auslesen und die fps auslesen dann initialisieren wir die
datei damit und dann schreiben wir kontinuierlich in die datei so das heißt wir gucken jetzt auch
wenn die datei sich nicht öffnen lässt dann dann geben wir mal eine log message aus und sagen
warning omega lull irgendwas können wir nachher noch ordentliche ordentliche fehler meldung
einschreiben ok und ab jetzt schreibe ich einfach alles was in diesem buffer drin ist in die datei
das müsste doch jetzt eigentlich ohne probleme funktionieren ihr wisst immer wenn ich das sage
geht es wahrscheinlich nicht also also sagen wir hier buffer wie machen wir das jetzt am besten
wir machen wir mal eine schleife und vielleicht vielleicht sollte ich das auch besser in einem
eigenen task starten hier egal wir kommen erstmal auf funktioniert also wartet mal also buffer
genau einfach alles was in diesem buffer drinne steht in die datei schreiben in dem buffer steht
drinne die letzten elf sekunden und bis ende so also packets also packet doppelt ich habe noch
eine idee wir könnten es im sekundentakt schreiben dass es nicht so nicht so viel iow nicht so viel
iow produziert was ist das eine gute idee also es ist immer besser wenn man wenn man sachen in
die datei schreibt wenn man das am stück macht und nicht irgendwie ein byte ein byte ein byte
ein byte sondern einfach gesammelt beim 20 mb sekunde warten beim 20 mb immer immer besser so
dass wir buffern das jetzt mal für für eine sekunde geht das so was ich da mache so und
jetzt ist es nämlich eine liste mit paketen packets ha ha exzellent exzellent exzellent so
right nee nicht buffer file right packets achte es geht ja nicht das muss weil weil da ist ja nix was
packets akzeptiert ok also public void right mehrere packets zum schreiben endl packets
packet warum es sink warum nicht ach so nee nee nee das ist nicht das ist nicht dass der
irgendwie buffert oder so großartig auf der festplatte das ist in den mechanismus in c
scharp eingebaut dass du code so ungefähr so schreiben kannst wie synchroner code aber
unter der haube händel der dann das für dich dass er zum beispiel wenn du sagst ich warte
jetzt hier auf das ergebnis dass er da nicht blockt sondern quasi an den thread der es
aufgerufen hat zurück gibt also das ist quasi mit eingebauten mechanismus dass das ganze nicht
blockt obwohl man das so ähnlich schreibt wie synchron das hat nichts mit nichts mit
asynchron auf in den cache von der festplatte zu tun oder so jetzt schreiben wir das hier rein
nicht wie bei go ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht wie es bei go ist so jetzt schreiben wir die
dinger hier rein weil man könnte man könnte hier noch einen stopp noch noch cancellation
token angeben so jetzt bin ich aber wirklich äußerst gespannt ob das klappt was ich hier
gebaut habe ich bin wirklich total matt im kopf ich bin schon gar nicht mehr wo ich hin da so
packets right packets ok nice also von der idee her sollte jetzt eine datei also wenn ich ihm
jetzt eine nachricht schicke er soll aufnehmen und aber nicht tausend mal please nicht tausend mal
nicht tausend mal dann sollte der jetzt sagen ich habe eine nachricht bekommen zum aufnehmen
er legt eine datei an plupp mp4 erwartet auf das erste packet aus von der kamera was schon längst
da sein sollte aber nur falls es noch nicht da ist dann öffnet die datei mit diesen parametern
sprich mit diesem code mit dieser auflösung mit diesen fps wenn ich sagte keck weh und an
der stelle sollte dann übrigens auch return und nicht irgendwas anderes machen und dann
schreibt er einfach und endlich lang in die datei cancelen können wir noch nicht wobei
wir können cancelen ich habe eine idee wir können cancelen wir können sogar relativ easy cancelen
was pass cancellation tocken habe ich cancellation tocken an den moment das ist das falsche ich
mache das hier übrigens mal kurz raus nehme erst mal hier output und dann zeigen wir hier
warum ist zuerst den green markiert weil rider mit denkt und sagt ich möchte hier vielleicht
was zum abbrechen rein reinschieben zum beispiel könnte könnte ich hier so was dann übergeben
das machen wir das machen wir jetzt auch das ist einfach nur rider logik der sagt mir hey ich habe
gesehen du hast was zum abbrechen warum übergibst du das hier nicht einfach das war jetzt nämlich
auch source cancelation tocken nee tocken das geht gar nicht cancelation manchmal ist die
syntax echt nicht so ganz obvious so weil jetzt kann ich nämlich sagen cancel after keine ahnung
fünf sekunden das heißt er macht jetzt automatisch die aufnahme aus ich brauche keine
cancel funktion so output hier das schauen wir mal ob das jetzt funktioniert ich mache
immer ein output rein ob der obs ob der jetzt auch schreibt right weg also sprich der sollte
jetzt einmal in der sekunde einmal in der sekunde sollte der dort jetzt was reinschreiben
schauen wir mal ob das klappt also mal und er sollte dann abbrechen und er sollte dann
abbrechen ok right right 5 sekunden um 5 sekunden um ok ja aber fast aber fast ja also was hat er für
schmerzen taskbar ach so es ist gar nichts kaputt gegangen es ist gar nichts kaputt gegangen das
ist die standard exception die man kriegt wenn man wenn man cancelt oh jetzt kann ich euch mal
neue c sharp feature zeigen richtig big brain feature was die von microsoft wieder eingebaut
haben also also warum diese fehlermeldung jetzt kommt ist folgendes wenn man das macht dass dort
net framework intern bei allen essungen sachen die man canceln kann wenn man den essung vorgang
cancelt mit so einem cancellation token in dem fall hier war mache ich das nach 5 sekunden wenn
man das nach 5 sekunden abricht dann wirft das ding eine exception nämlich eine task cancel
cancel exception oder eine operation cancel exception das ist sinnvoll weil es kann ja sein dass ich
irgendwie drauf reagieren will wenn abgebrochen wird ja weil es ist ja ein unterschied ob
beispielsweise einen vorgang fehlerfrei bis zum ende gelaufen ist oder ob ich den vorgang in
der mitte abgebrochen habe also kann ja sein dass ich da unterschiedlich drauf reagieren will
so das heißt ich muss da jetzt ein try catch drumherum machen und jetzt kann ich euch mal
excellent ein neues c sharp feature zeigen und ich bin mal gespannt wer von euch das kennt
ich kannte es bis vor ein paar tagen nämlich nicht so das hier ist jetzt die unschöne variante
ja also wir ketschen einfach alles alle exceptions egal was was was auftritt was man machen kann seit
c sharp weiß ich nicht sieben oder so ich keine ahnung kann man nämlich sagen catch exception
kann man sagen wenn wenn exception ist task task cancel exception oder ist operation cancel exception
das ist neu sieben sagt der chat ja das ist neu das geht noch nicht so lange also sprich
früher musste man das so machen also nur mal so zu nur mal das hier ist doof weil das hier
ketscht jegliche fehlermeldung die auftreten also ich erwarte ja ich erwarte dass hier jetzt eine
task cancellation exception kommt oder eine operation cancellation exception so die zwei
sachen erwarte ich sollte da jetzt eine andere exception kommen zum beispiel irgendwie i0 exception
oder sowas dann will ich die eigentlich gar nicht capturen sondern will die vielleicht sogar dass
mein programm abkackt ja weil es ist nicht erwartet an der stelle und ganz ehrlich ein
programm was abkackt bei nicht erwarteten sachen ist meistens sogar besser als ein
programm was weiter läuft bei nicht erwarteten sachen so und das heißt wenn ich einfach nur
exception ketsche dann gilt das für alle exceptions außer native code geschichten die nicht so was
ich früher machen konnte ist folgendes früher hätte ich das so schreiben können ich ketsche
eine task cancellation exception und ich ketsche eine operation cancel exception so hätte ich das
früher machen können machts aber unnötig lang zumal ich ja witzigerweise war beiden nix machen
will außer vielleicht was loggen deswegen kann man jetzt so machen alles in einem schreiben ich
gebe zu bei zwei exceptions ist es noch fast egal aber wenn sie mal drei vier fünf sind ist das
hier schon nice ja ok so gut sollte ich was loggen eigentlich muss ich da nichts loggen
weil wozu es wurde gecancelt und alles ist gut da schauen wir mal ob es funktioniert also erst
mal datai löschen epos writer monarch s lub übrigens es stimmt auch die farbe in meinem
terminal nicht und so ganz ganz merkwürdig was das seit dem update gemacht hat ist die
cancellation exception nicht in ein aggregate exception gewappt das kann sein aber nicht
wenn man erwartet wenn man erwartet sollte das unwrapped werden soweit die tv ok also die
datei ist weg jetzt schauen wir mal ob das funktioniert wir machen noch ein paar locks
wir machen noch ein paar locks also wir schreiben jetzt mal hier lock info keine ahnung capture
startet und hier unten schreiben was machen dafür und hier unten schreiben wir noch irgendwie
capture end oder sowas capture finished und das machen wir raus das heißt der sollte jetzt fünf
sekunden aufnehmen also nee der sollte rückwirkend aufnehmen das sollte rückwirkend aufnehmen
deswegen lasse ich jetzt mal kurz laufen also ich lasse mal kurz laufen ich lasse mal zehn
sekunden laufen so und wenn jetzt alles funktioniert dann nimmt er jetzt elf sekunden rückwirkend auf
moment da nimmt er elf sekunden rückwirkend auf und noch mal fünf sekunden zusätzlich also das
heißt ich müsste dann 16 sekunden video haben wenn das alles funktioniert so wie ich mir das
gedacht habe was natürlich extrem nice ist weil wenn hier jemand durchs bild rennt wenn hier
jemand durchs bild läuft und ich erkenne dass eine person durchs bild gelaufen ist dann will
ich ja nicht aufnehmen ab dem zeitpunkt wo ich sie erkannt habe sondern zehn sekunden zurück
deswegen baffere ich zehn sekunden okay okay ich habe jetzt lange noch aufgenommen jetzt gucken
wir mal record ok capture startet 1 2 3 4 5 capture finished das sieht schon mal echt gut aus
so datal ist da 2,3 mb ff probe ist 15 sekunden ok fast es ist es ist fast richtig es ist fast
richtig ein bisschen ein bisschen plus minus gibt es immer ein bisschen plus minus gibt es
immer weil man muss ja auch dazu sagen das hier ist kein exaktes timing captain seacr yes richtig
exquisite ex also das hier ist nur eigentlich ist das hier gar nicht so geil weil das hier nimmt
nicht elf sekunden video auf das nimmt elf sekunden lang auf wie pakete reinkommen also
sprich da können durchaus mal ein paar pakete fehlen die vielleicht selbst aber schon eine
halbe sekunde lang gewesen wären also es wäre fast besser ich baffere das von hand indem ich hier
beispielsweise die package duration zähle oder so aber mal ganz ehrlich eigentlich ist das ok ich
meine scheiß drauf ob das jetzt eine sekunde länger oder kürzer ist ist doch jetzt eigentlich
dafür spar ich mir massig code ist doch ok so jetzt kommt natürlich die frage geht geht
die aufnahme überhaupt aber die müsste einstehen jop nice guck mal der capture sogar weiter wenn
die kamera neu startet exzellent sehr nice ok jetzt ist fertig es ging ja nur es ging ja nur
15 sekunden jetzt ist fertig so wir können jetzt mal gucken ob das auch mehrfach aufnehmen kann
ich da noch nicht wenn ich mehrfach aufnehme dann crash das ich habe das hier alles in diesem in
diesem in line start händler drin das funktioniert nicht aber das aufnehmen geht prinzipiell schon
mal das ist das ist sehr nice das ist sehr nice das gefällt mir das gefällt mir wirklich gut
ich mache jetzt mal was extra so eine extra metode für das wird es mir nämlich ein bisschen
voll private void start capture den start capture kommt dieser ganze schmatter von hier
und capture finished capture startet feil was brauche ich hier drin jetzt ich brauche den buffer
buffer unter teilnahme brauche ich also string filename und den buffer und das ganze muss
async sein und dass der chat sich nicht wieder beschwert async task können wir auch machen man
darf man soll ja eigentlich kein async void machen aber jetzt machen wir gerade so und
jetzt kann man das aufrufen das start capture filename ist blub.mp4 filename generieren wir
gleich noch und der buffer und jetzt ist das ein bisschen schöner jetzt blinkt man vor allem
ein bisschen besser wieder durch funktionieren sollte der ganze spaß immer noch connected
aber ich habe ich habe die aufnahmen gestartet vor die kamera bevor die kamera an war capture
started 1 2 3 4 5 jetzt capture finished wie lange machst du heute 20 minuten oder so so
da haben wir wieder 15 sekunden excellent weil warum haben wir 15 sekunden ich dachte ich
habe viel schneller aufgenommen das muss ich jetzt noch mal ausprobieren so weil wenn ich
jetzt schneller wenn ich jetzt hier schneller drücke mit dem curl dann müsste ich ja eigentlich
dürfte ich nicht so viel buffer nicht so viel scrollback buffer haben 11 sekunden ok siehste
er nimmt nur so viel auf er nimmt immer auf wie viel in meinem buffer drinne ist plus fünf
sekunden und jetzt habe ich das zu jetzt habe ich das schon gestartet die aufnahme bevor das 11
sekunden gebuffert waren deswegen ist es jetzt keine ahnung sechs sekunden plus fünf sekunden
ist bei 11 sekunden ok gut also das das scheint alles auf anhieb relativ relativ gut zu funktionieren
da ist aber irgendwo noch einen haken an irgendwas habe ich nicht gedacht bestimmt sonst müssen wir
noch einen gescheiten namen generieren das machen wir jetzt noch wir müssen noch gescheiten namen
generieren weil ich kann ja schlecht alle aufnahmen plupp punkt mp4 nennen ich mein plupp punkt mp4
mag ja vielleicht für eine aufnahme gut funktionieren aber für alle garantiert nicht das heißt wir
machen uns mal irgendwas was wir noch später in die datenbank schreiben können das mal irgendwie
public class capture capture info oder sowas man könnte auch einfach hochzählen man könnte sie auch
einfach hochzählen capture 1 2 3 ne aber wenn das jemand im filesystem mal sortieren will ist
besser wir nennen das wie den namen der kamera die aldi von der kamera und zeitzeitzeit timestamp
stamp jam ok also nachdem wir das später mal in datenbank schreiben wollen braucht das ding
der aldi sonst funktioniert das mit efchor nicht einfach ne random grid hier da habe ich auch schon
dran gedacht weil wir mapen ja in der datenbank später welche aufnahme zu welcher zeit das
ganze ist also man könnte wirklich ne random grid nehmen auf dem filesystem aber ich finde
es ist nicht sonderlich benutzerfreundlich wenn der mal echt ins filesystem geht und danach sucht
dann ist es glaube ich schon besser wenn die aufnahme heißt wie die die wie die kamera und
und motion dit obs motion detection war kamera und urzeit ist wahrscheinlich besser zu finden
als random goods ok dann also was müssen wir uns merken bei so einer aufnahme die interne aldi in
der datenbank ok wir müssen uns merken von welcher kamera das ganze kommt wir müssen uns merken
hier war das gestartet wurde file extension punkter s das würde ich sofort machen das problem ist
warum das nicht geht ist folgendes ich sage hier av gass format und wenn wenn wenn die file
extension punkter s ist oder monac s dann sagt er wahrscheinlich dass er das format nicht kennt was
ich machen könnte ist monac s punkt mp4 das könnte ich machen das machen wir das machen wir
aber mp4 muss es heißen oder aber ich muss hartcoded oder aber ich muss hartcoded sagen
neben mp4 das kann ich auch machen capture service das mit der datei mit mit der kammer
aber noch mal kurz also also ok uns interessiert das start von der aufnahme uns interessiert das
ende von der aufnahme uns interessiert was das ausgelöst hat nuppi 84 twitch prime dankeschön
für den sub excellent subscription big brain sub prime subscription sogar
die länge der aufnahme ja finde ich auch gut flix twitch prime
huge massive iq sub die länge können wir einfach ausrechnen mit start durch ende
an die start durch ende ende minus start alter ich bin 36 ich glaube wir haben
kein ausrufezeichen alter aber ich bin viel zu alt mittlerweile schon
können wir können wir sagen timespan dur dur duration oder scam train ist schon wieder am start so
und da sagen wir jetzt duration ist was new timespan im moment das muss man gar nicht sagen man
kann einfach sagen end minus start da kommt ein timespan raus genau ok also duration können wir
machen dann mit was das ausgelöst wurde 13 14 monate excellent subscription das ist ja schon
14 monate ist ja so moment das will ich jetzt noch mal schnell fertig machen also wir brauchen
den trigger was es ausgelöst hat wir machen wir so was wie has error vielleicht ist es irgendwie
abgekackt das will ich vielleicht im frontend mal zeigen dann machen wir so was wie eine error
message falls es einen error hat und wir merken uns ob das oder ist ist ist ist ist ist aktiv
kommen ist das ein dynamisch berechtigt property ja genau das ist die kurzschreibweise das ist
die kurzschreibweise von mal gucken ob das writer umformatieren kann ja das ist die
kurzschreibweise zu dem hier was natürlich irgendwie schicker ist ja ok so und jetzt
haben wir noch den name den name von der datei so jetzt jetzt ist mein file so da versagt jetzt
mein brain weil ich will so was hier machen also der name ist wird automatisch zusammengesetzt
aus kammer moment was machen hier automatisch zusammengesetzt aus camera name underscore dann
was es für einen aufnahme typ ist was denn sonst noch und die uhrzeit ich weiß nicht
oder da habe ich jetzt keinen bock drauf daytime format alter was ist ein gutes zeitformat was
ist ein gutes zeitformat für video für video start also sagen wir so was keine ahnung so
was in der richtung wie 20 20 20 20 11 20 wir machen das ami format das ist in dem fall
praktischer weil das dann sortierter ist ich mache es mal mit underscore so und dann dann
minute also sagen wir in der stunde 21 uhr 45 und 40 sekunden so was in millisekunden so was
hier so jetzt ist plus die greifpreis frage wie formatier ich meine start duration so dass das
funktioniert da stehe ich immer hardcore auf dem schlauch sich ab daytime format danno ist
bestimmt das ernsthaft also danno wenn das stimmt das ist ja aber ja echt big massive brain
ich muss da immer nachgucken ich kann mir das net merken ist es zu streng oder ist es format
und dann sowas hier
was was hat rider denn für schmerzen hier replace with formats mit was für
einem ding was ist das das geht das ist neu das ist neu das kenne ich auch nicht seit wann gibt
es das hieß das ich habe vergessen wie das wie wurde das genannt format specifier
zu streng ist alt aber das hier ist neu dass du nicht mehr zu streng schreiben musst
benutzer definiert das format ok ich habe keine ahnung vor wann das ist ich nehme das einfach
zur kenntnis dass es funktioniert das gem train ist durch exzellent vielleicht stimmt das könnte
es kann sein dass es hier mit streng interpolation kommt ja das das ist das wird es wahrscheinlich
sein so wo wir gerade dabei sind ist das überhaupt die richtige richt also dd dd
ha ha ist die stunde von eins bis zwei gibt es die ne ne ne ne ne ne groß groß groß
please please nicht klar nicht nicht na na zeit na datum ok aber keine na zeit ok mal schauen ok
das ist die letzte amtshandlung heute mal schauen ob das klappt fallen nehmen also das heißt wir
sagen so hier vor info new capture info kapture info so also was brauchen wir da wir machen jetzt
erstmal die camera ist die start kann ich schon setzen start ist daytime now end kann ich noch
nicht setzen all die auch nicht trigger kann ich setzen und der rest kann ich nicht kann ich nicht
setzen so und jetzt sagen wir hier mal teilnehmen so mal schauen ob das klappt jetzt wie die datei
ob die ob die jetzt so heißt wie wir uns das vorgestellt haben so record oh ich habe mp4
vergessen mp4 fehlt guck übrigens hier unable to find suitable output suitable output vor null
ok das ding muss tatsächlich punkt mp4 heißen sonst geht es nicht ok monach es tatsächlich
also ok monach es punkt mp4 muss sein sonst erkennt das nicht hoffentlich geht das capture
started capture finished wohnzimmer motion 20 20 11 20 21 59 10 perfekt ich würde ja die
ordner ändern kann nehmen dann timestamp dann triggern du meinst den timestamp zuerst warum
der chat wieder ach so du meinst der kam der kameraname als ordner der kameraname ist nicht
unic eigentlich müsste ich kamerai die und kameraname zusammennehmen als ordner weil der
kameraname ist nicht unic es kann ja sein dass leute zwei kameras im wohnzimmer haben die id
ist unic das wird hier natürlich auch gleiche probleme machen aber zeigt mal her wo aber das
überlege ich mir morgen funktioniert bäm wie ist der stand aufnahme funktioniert aufnahme
funktioniert was passiert eigentlich wenn ich zweimal aufnehmen dann krasht oder ich hab
schon startet wie das geht das geht einfach ich kann einfach so zweimal aufnehmen ob ich
irgendwas verpasst gut warum nicht was passiert wenn ich zu schnell hintereinander startet
dann kackte ab wenn ich zu schnell hintereinander startet kackte ab
lustig damit hätte ich ehrlich gesagt nicht gerechnet dass das funktioniert aber es ist
gar nicht so schön wenn ich mehrere sachen gleichzeitig starten kann ich sollte das abfragen
ich sollte das abfangen dass ich nicht mehrere sachen gleichzeitig starten kann weil es
ergibt ja keinen sinn warum sollte ich für eine kamera mehr als ein capture typ gleichzeitig
da könnte ja einer im webinterface da könnte ja in einem webinterface den hier machen oder
hätte 50 aufnahmen ne das ist doof wir können es auch im webinterface locken dass es nicht geht
aber ich habe noch eine andere idee wisst ihr was richtig cool wäre jetzt ist es ja so wenn
der erkennt dass jemand durchs bild gelaufen ist hier dann löst er eine 5 sekunden aufnahme
aus oder wir machen es mal auf 30 sekunden aufnahme und rückwirkend 11 sekunden also sprich der nimmt
41 sekunden auf ab dem zeitpunkt wo eine person erkannt hat 10 11 sekunden zurück und 30 sekunden
vorwärts wisst ihr was richtig geil wäre wenn wenn wir das hinbekommen dass wenn der mehrere
detections hat innerhalb einer aufnahme zeitspanne dass er erst dann immer erweitert also sprich wenn
er jetzt eine person erkennt und er wirft die aufnahme an und er erkennt fünf sekunden später
wieder was dass er dann keine zweite aufnahme anmacht so dann da sondern dass er die genau genau
so was wie kämpfer schreibt sondern dass er quasi diese 30 sekunden erweitert
irgendwie sowas ich schreibe mir das mal auf dass ich nicht vergesse kann man den
cancellation token anpassen an der stelle für was nee na das klappt nicht weil beim nächsten
durchlauf macht er das hier neu das heißt ich müsste mir das speichern das machen aber nicht
heute mehr aber das heißt ich müsste mir das speichern ich kann jetzt nicht einfach hier blind
von oben nach unten durchlaufen ich müsste mir das speichern also ich sprich ich müsste mir diese
capture moment moment also an der stelle ist das cancellation token eh schon kacke
an der will ich das einfach mit hier will ich das token überhaupt nicht drin haben
das token will ich in der in der dort wo ich das aufrufe generieren also quasi da
so aber ich müsste mir das speichern also ich müsste mir das hier merken und sagen okay wenn
die kamera schon läuft dann hol dir das alte das heißt ich müsste dass ich müsste das
cancellation token hier drin speichern und wenn oder in irgendeinem dictionary oder so und wenn
er das nächste mal reingeht oder schon eine laufende aufnahme hat dann nimmt er das alte
extended das und return einfach irgendwie sowas in der richtung also ich mache jetzt
mal schnell irgendwas wie gesagt wir machen gleich schluss nur dass ich dass ich morgen
ich vergesse immer ein dictionary immer im zweifelsfall sind wir lieber ein bisschen
langsamer dafür das red safe also wir müssen uns speichern für die für die id nee moment
moment nicht für die id von der kamera kamera nicht kamera info capture info sondern wir
wollen ja pro aufnahme typ einmal erlauben also aufnahme typ sprich ist es manuell timer
oder motion detection also sprich da können wir jetzt mal neues die sharp feature verwenden
was so nicht so lang gibt können ich hier sagen wir wollen als key nicht ein wert verwenden
sondern zwei werte verwenden id capture trigger so nennen wir es mal irgendwie active active
capture cap turis gleich so und da müsste ich das speichern da müsste ich quasi wenn
ich wenn ich starte und das hier müsste ich auf jeden fall erwarten so das ist das ist
nichts mit erst und das müsste auf jeden fall erwarten dass ich danach was anderes
machen kann wenn wenn die aufnahme fertig ist ob das so klappt so ok wenn es heißt
wenn ich die aufnahme starte dann sagen wir hier active active captures what the fuck
at try at zwar die kamera id und den trigger und diese capture inform so und wenn das
fertig ist dann entferne ich es einfach wieder so und dadurch dass ich hier erwarte macht
er das auch erst wenn die aufnahme fertig ist so und dann kann ich hier oben ach du
scheiße ob das ob das klappt dann kann ich hier oben gucken if active captures also sprich
gibt es das schon gibt es das wirklich red safe ist das auch nicht das ist zwar beim
zugriff zu red safe aber zwischendrin kann immer noch ok probieren wir also gibt es das
schon wenn es das gibt lull ich weiß gar kein bessere namen für wenn es das gibt und
der trigger gleich gleich motion detection ist dann ach fuck ich habe ja ich habe das
cancellation token gar nicht also brauche ich hier nicht die oh fuck also brauche ich
hier nicht nur die capture info sondern ich brauche vielleicht soll ich da irgendwie
den eigenen typ für machen sondern ich brauche noch die das cancellation token oh exquisite
oh jetzt wird schön lesbar hm fein fein fein ah yes kann es kann er das auto formatieren
also wer wollte nicht schon immer mal so ein dictionary in seiner klasse drin haben sieht
das nett toll aus keiner kann also wer das entziffern kann der ist echt nicht nicht
schlecht so das heißt ich schreibe jetzt nicht nur die info rein sondern ich schreibe
jetzt auch noch ich habe schon wieder vergessen wie es heißt wo habe ich wo habe ich meine
dictionary wo ist es hin wo ist es hin ich habe sie oben ich habe sie unten drunter
gemacht ok also da mache ich das ding sondern ich mache die cancellation token source auch
noch rein ok ok und jetzt sage ich lull source cancel after 30 sekunden ok testen ob es
funktioniert testen wir machen wir mal hier extent schreiben wir jetzt dahin ok also
zum testen fünf sekunden aufnahme ist normal fünf sekunden aufnahme ist normal das heißt
nach fünf sekunden cancel das normalerweise capture startet eins zwei drei vier fünf
stopp so und wenn ich jetzt das noch mal starte und noch mal extended guck mal aber moment
moment und moment nein ich muss die return ich darf nicht weitermachen ok das war fast
fast fast noch mal noch mal ok ok fünf sekunden extended extended extended extended ok und
jetzt sollte es 30 sekunden gehen also bis 50 das scheint zu funktionieren weil es
wäre ja schon fertig ok es gibt zwei wirklich keinen endmeter er bricht komplett ab kackt
ab oder er hört gar nicht mehr auf aufzunehmen oder es klappt so drei zwei eins bäm habt
es gesehen easy und jetzt haben wir fvlc wie lang ist der spaß oh ich muss gucken dass
ich im keyframe starte noch das muss ich gleich noch aufschreiben irgendwo hier kann du start
bis keyframe weil ansonsten ist die fängt die aufnahme so an guck mal jetzt haben wir
40 sekunden aufgenommen wir haben 11 sekunden 11 sekunden zurück ist ja das kommt so ungefähr
hin ok ok nice nice also das heißt wir bekommen jetzt wir starten jetzt eine motion aufnahme
und solange weiter motion ist im bild nimmt er die weiter auf das doch cool und dann also
quasi immer 30 sekunden also immer 11 sekunden vorne dran und dann immer 30 sekunden hinten
dran bis zu bis zu unlimited also wenn es immer wenn quasi den ganzen tag leute durch
laufen dann hat er den ganzen tag in den video fall ok ich mache jetzt noch mal ein
eine änderung die mir gerade ein dass ich nicht vergesse wo habe ich dann hingeschrieben
to do keyframe start with keyframe ich glaube das ist relativ einfach dass wir mit einem
keyframe starten ich sage ihm einfach output buffer überspringen einfach überspringen
einfach alles bis zum keyframe also wir sagen quasi sowas wie hier skip skip skip element
from the observance until specified specified start time kann ich nicht sagen skip until
2 nein ok ich weiß es nicht gib mal einen shout out für i am luci excellent ja ich
shout out wir machen morgen weiter ist schon so spät ich kann immer richtig denken ok
wenn ich mir dann wenn ich mir dein profil bild angucke dann gefällt euch bestimmt das
hier was für eine sprache ist das c sharp war das ja nice schön dass ihr dabei gewesen
seid wieder heute ich habe jetzt hier urlaub bis januar was hat das mit der 1 mit sich
auf sich mal mal aus rufzeichen 1 da gibt schon eine erklärung für das welche im stream
mehrfach gefragt moment die lied admin sein für alle ich glaube es geht los darf es
nicht lösen ok leute also wir sehen uns bis denn macht gut zu